so we got this viral clip from reporter
Ahad aliyahu we're at a pride event
they're chanting we're coming for your
children this story is going massively
viral even being carried by the
corporate press which is surprising to
me I think it's because regular people
are sick and tired of the extreme
Behavior we've been seeing creeping into
the mainstream as it pertains to Pride
events the Bud Light effect has become
very real for every major corporation in
two ways the first you're gonna lose
money if you Embrace this stuff because
it's gone too far and the second you're
gonna make money if you cover the
stories and make videos about it we
talked about this early on I said a lot
of creators a lot of influence a lot of
you know people who make videos or
whatever are going to start jumping on
this because they can clearly see
there's a path to virality in covering
these stories and talking about
addressing the issue and now seeing the
corporate press actually address it
surprising to me to be completely honest
but we'll talk about that and we'll talk
about this clip that's gone viral from
the culture War podcast from last week
where our guest from The majority report
explicitly defended she believed that
children of 10 years old should be using
Grindr
and we have to discuss the morality
behind that the question being do these
leftists actually believe children
should be equipped to engage in illegal
activity or should be become victims of
adult Predators or are they just saying
whatever they think the left wants them
to say in which case they're driving
themselves off a cliff we'll talk about
that in a whole bunch more we got a
bunch of crazy stories they want to
impeach mayor Garland there's a new
report about the bite Administration
colluding with big Tech to censor people
we kind of know all of that stuff so
we'll talk about those issues and what's
going on in the in the culture wars it
pertains to get what go broke Disney
losing 900 million dollars with all of
their uh last with several of their last
releases because yeah I think uh I think
we're winning this one I think I think
regular people have had enough and are
just saying yo I'm sick of how crazy
things have gotten before we get into
all of that my friends head over to
castbrew.com and pick up cast brew
coffee this is our coffee company not
only will it be the greatest cup of
coffee you've ever had it will be the
only well I shouldn't say only but it'll
be one of the best cups of coffee
helping you fight communism that's right
we sponsor ourselves so when you buy
cash through you're helping support this
show the work that we do and we're
building a parallel economy the coffee
shop is currently under construction
every time we start working on a new
part of the building we get an update
there's a not this is best this has got
to be cleared out and all that crazy
stuff and it's a historic building so
it's taking forever but this is the
ultimate goal to create real world
physical locations that people can hang
out get exposed to content like ours and
say Stephen Crowder and Viva and Barnes
Etc to see those videos when they're
buying their coffee so that we can get a
foothold in the center of suburban
spaces and urban spaces and with your
support by buying Casper coffee we will
get there also don't forget to go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
tonight just after the show wraps around
10 p.m you don't want to miss it and you
can also download the mobile app by
clicking mobile app it's available
currently for Android the Android and
Apple apps are currently done but the
app stores haven't allowed the app in
just yet so you can directly download
the Android app to your phone on our
website so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
Terry Schilling
hey guys thanks so much for having me
this is a really exciting topic for me
this is all I do is talk about how the
left is trying to groom our children
sexually and in many other ways so
perfect night to come on and uh talk
about everything I've learned over the
past few years well right on what is it
you do do you work for an organization
yeah so I'm the president of a group
called American principles project and
we brand ourselves as big family right
so like everyone in DC has a special
interest group there's big Pharma Big
Oil big tobacco we're big family we make
politicians pay a price when they hurt
our kids or indoctrinate our kids in
schools uh we get parents a voice in
politics and uh we think that politics
is a really important thing and it
actually can drive the culture and you
know when you change the law you can
change the culture and so we operate
from a very simple premise right on we
got Phil Labonte hanging out as well how
you doing I am filibonti lead singer of
All That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary it's good to be
back what's up Ian oh well so many
things Phil let's talk about it tonight
on this beautiful Monday night Ian also
coming at you live everybody what's
happening search yo uh sorry about the
audio guys the reason there is a buzz
because we have two window units running
right now and there's not really much I
can do otherwise yeah I would die of a
heat exhaustion so answers.com our AC
broke so we we have two portable units
and a fan running and it is still like
80 degrees in here so uh it's still hot
it sucks but yeah so you know we'll be
getting sweaty in in the room yeah yep
we'll we'll figure it out in in in due
time but uh yeah so shall we get on with
the news let's do it all right the first
store we got is from timcast.com New
York City drag March participants chant
we are coming for your children actually
I don't think I can uh show the video
because they're nude so I have to turn
on the blur here that's cool and then uh
yeah and then let's see if I boot it up
is it gonna is it gonna blur it's not so
let's refresh and see if it worked now
okay there we go
[Music]
all right
okay so the chance we're not going
shopping afterwards the fact that they
all know the change like they know what
this chant is it was planned in advance
they're saying we're coming for your
children here's what gets interesting
this is uh I think now I can remove the
blur this is ABC7 we're coming for your
children video of NYC drag March parade
stirs outright show even the corporate
press is covering this podcaster Tim
Poole shared a video of the event I mean
technically I did it was timcast news
filmed by alad aliyahu several outlets
including the Daily Mail and Newsweek
have reported the videos from New York
City's Pride weekend people can be seen
in the video walking through a park
wearing colorful apparel some dressed in
Dragon others topless and they're
chanting that they're coming for our
children
at a certain point it's not a joke that
video came out a while ago from the San
Francisco Gay Men's Choir singing we're
coming for your children and people were
like hey that's alarming and what did
the media say it's a joke they're being
silly and it's no they're not joking no
they're not they they actually mean it
there are numerous videos going around
right now that I can't show on YouTube
one of them depicts a man in tighty
whities spreading his legs and
cheeks in front of children and then
gyrating and thrusting himself at the
kids
I can't show you that video I mean it's
hard enough to describe on a show like
this
Twitter is censoring these videos
if you try to retweet it they're getting
suppressed people aren't seeing the the
posts and then the videos themselves it
says this tweet is unavailable and this
is the scary thing about censorship I
understand you want to censor this so
that kids don't see it
you put a sensitive filter on it you
don't make it impossible for people to
see because the fact that people can't
see this is what's prolonging it so when
you go to someone and tell them this is
what they're doing this is what the left
has been doing they're grooming kids
they say prove it you try to find the
video the video's gone because Twitter
is censoring it out of a fear that
advertisers will flick the platform no
that's exactly right there the lefts the
the transgender movement the left's best
argument for the past decade or so when
it comes to our kids has been it isn't
happening right just a straight up
denial that there's anything going on
with kids and that's all started to
change ever since all of everyone has a
tick tock Channel everyone has a YouTube
channel and because these kids are
bragging about it they're bragging about
getting double mastectomies and and
we're seeing this stuff in our kids
schools covid was awesome Silver Lining
to expose parents to what their kids are
experiencing but no that's exactly right
to him they we have to be able to talk
about this stuff and we can't protect
it's already out there I mean they're
they're doing this on the pride praise
the pride parades have been out of
control for at least the last decade
right like this is not new I've been to
Pride parades they always have weird
nude crazy stuff going on the leather
they've had the puppy guys you know out
there this has always been a level of
weirdness to this and um and at the
center of it right trans rights you have
it like they have special privileges now
right like I'm not able to go into the
streets and dance naked in a you know a
St Patrick's Day but that's pride in
general that's always been that way I
mean we've talked about it when I was a
kid you'd go to a pride parade and they
would be doing gratuitous things they'd
be naked so more more uh more
specifically when I was a kid my mom did
not let me go outside during Pride
because we had a cafe on North Halsted
in Chicago the pride parade would come
and she'd say go inside and don't come
outside because the things they were
doing
when I was uh maybe six seven years ago
in La people I knew in L.A were like oh
yeah when pride comes around they were
talking about how they all got naked and
would run around run around fully fully
nude it's like I'm like isn't that
illegal and they're like nobody cares
it's like okay well look at the people
in the cities don't care does someone
care I mean the the thing is maybe they
haven't been vocal maybe they have been
kind of like worried about what their
neighbors would say or whatever because
of the tone nowadays but I really find
it hard to believe that people don't
care I think people were afraid to say
something because of the fact that they
felt like they were going to be
ostracized when in reality they probably
were still the The Quiet Mind uh
majority most people don't want their
children to be exposed to to kink in the
streets of a major city and I think that
the stuff with uh Bud Light and Dylan
Mulvaney finally gave your average
person the courage to stand up and say
hold on I don't really approve of this
you know I want to see I want to see a
little more modesty in public no one's
talking about going into your
bedroom and deciding who you can sleep
with or can't sleep with or at least the
average person I'm sure there are some
some religious people that want to
you know want to get into the into the
business of what is going on in your
bedroom but the average person that is
just kind of living their life and
doesn't really pay a lot of attention to
politics they don't want their kids
exposed to nude men in the streets what
about like a dude in a diaper with a dog
helmet on
[Laughter]
that could that you know I bet you the
the average guy the welder that welds in
sin in uh South Dakota he probably wants
his kids to be exposed to a guy in a
diaper with a dog like a guy can go
shirtless in tight shorts any day of the
week walk down the street he can put on
a dog mask he can walk down the street
but like if he puts on a strap you know
fake strap on it or whatever now it's
becoming sexual technically Oriel a real
one but like I mean how is like wearing
a diaper as your only thing not sexual
for an adult anyway it's weird
it's all Kink though that's the part of
the thing is that that Tim's talked
about before is is this isn't about
actually being proud of your sexuality
it's about exhibitionism narcissism and
kink yeah well and I I also think though
that it makes sense right this is a
movement built on pride and that pride
has now turned into hubris to where
they're pushing
transgender bathing suit suits for
little kids at Target and they didn't
think there was going to be a
consequence they what those were adult
bathing suits no no they didn't they
expose that it was for for little kids
no those were adult bathing suits so
they they did have kids clothing and
like onesies that said like pride and
things like that the tuck friendly
bathing suit was was an adult bathing
suit okay so the thing is though
regardless of Target did that right but
they're still trans kids stuff sorry
real quick the funny thing is like that
was the defense we got from the
corporate press like no no no that that
section where they're selling the kids
club that has all the stuff on it the
bathing's for tucking was for the adults
in the same section and it's like okay
I'm glad you brought up hubris man this
is um pride is on my mind a lot and like
how it's a Catholic sin but an American
virtue and I think this whole we're
coming for you rhetoric is hubristic
like who do you think you are right
let's coexist with me and threaten that
you're gonna come for my children it's a
celebration of a conquered religion
every year when Pride goes out and when
they are out there in the streets
celebrating they're celebrating that
they have their celebrating their
victory over Christianity and I'm an
agnostic I'm not the guy that's gonna
sit there and say he's a little too
explicit for me but you think I don't
think it's over Christianity I think
it's just I I don't I don't it's it's we
refer to focus as a non-theistic
religion but it's amorphous it is it is
it is boundaryless borderless it is just
it's more of a celebration of likeness
these are people who are going out and
being like we are we we have a social
group that's all they're saying
there's no logic there's no rules
there's no morals as long as you agree
to adhere to the group you're good if
you deviate in any way you're bad
they're not celebrating a deity they're
not celebrating an ideology they're
celebrating an amalgam of various social
theories and aspects mashed together
which often contradict each other I
don't disagree with you in that point
but I do think that they're celebrating
a victory over what is considered normal
or what has been considered absolutely
absolutely but Christianity like I look
if you go to these events they'll tell
you they don't like Christianity but
they couldn't tell you anything about it
and it's not on their minds yeah it's
the Christianity that Jon Stewart told
him who's out there and that's where
they get there they're not going out
there because of Christianity they don't
like it but they do like Islam
seriously like not all of them but a lot
of them do until they find out how Islam
feels about them nope they still like it
no but they'll move on just like that
they will move on the dialectic will
continue because as soon as Islam
becomes the conservative in their eyes
then they will move on just like they do
to gay men how gay men aren't you know
you're not queer enough if you're a a
gay white male like you're not queer
enough and you you get left behind
that's what happened to people like Milo
and and but it's it's you know Brenda
striking Brenda strick as gay man and
and people like it's been it's been
years since uh we've seen Islam uh
Muslims protesting lgbtq stuff like and
then they're still very much like oh
it's fine it is starting to change
though there was uh up in Michigan
that's Dearborn yeah it wasn't in
Dearborn it was a town near uh uh
Detroit not necessarily Dearborn but
probably close enough suburb where they
said no Pride flags on public display
and they said because we don't put
anyone's flags on public display we only
do the American flag or or the flags of
Nations and then they got mad about it I
saw um in the UK government buildings
are flying the the progress pride flag
in the U.S this is a flag it's a symbol
of a global
it's it's a it's a global takeover it is
it is a non-theistic religion it is a
global cult the fact that foreign
countries are flying this flag says a
lot the fact that you fact that U.S
embassies fly the flag says a lot it is
creepy and it and it should not be
allowed so I look I don't know if we'll
get anyone in Congress to be like hey
you know you can't fly flags like this
you know on government buildings they're
doing it anyway I can't speak for these
other countries but it is creepy and I
wonder
when I see that I'm like is that the
flag of like the One World Government
you know what I mean like not literally
in the sense of One World Government but
is that the flag of the Cross borders
internationalist ethos
it's at least the flag for the activists
that will get us to a One World
Government right like they'll have
something else more generic that appeals
to more people but I I like that idea of
passing laws that say that in in
government buildings you can only fly
government Flags right like the the the
American why is it like what is their
argument against the American flag being
the flag that they hate America I
understand that but like if you're on TV
right so like the professionals what do
they say because the American flag
really does represent everyone gay
straight trans whatever whether you like
it or not it represents America uh so
like why don't they just fly the
American flag like if I was an LGBT
liberalism yeah they they hate
liberalism they hate America
so it repulses them yes
and here's the crazy thing too there's a
video I saw to France where during their
pride March someone climbed up to a
second floor about someone's second
second floor balcony and ripped down the
French flag it's not just America it is
these all these countries having some
kind of weird shared internet cult
and they're they're they're bubbling up
in a bunch of different countries the
patriarchy they want to smash the
picture oh sure the white privilege no I
think is what it stands they are the
patients times ten like remember
literally wokeness is Hardcore
patriarchy yeah like the the at the the
the the advocacy against the rights of
women is it's crazy it's racist too it
splits up black kids and tells them
their skin color means something and
like people become racist and they're
like so so so counter productive it's
wild wild that humans think that this is
something
in this context and I know we did talk
about this uh on Friday but I do want to
bring it up now we have this clip from
the culture War podcast where I was in
conversation with Emma vigiland of the
majority report co-host and considering
what we saw with this Pride event I I
want to play this clip and and discuss
it more in in in depth so I'm going to
play it for you now here we go you're
the one arguing for uh you're the one
arguing for censorship yes I mean I
don't I don't really mind that stuff I
mean do you are you in favor of children
seeing violence on television no scares
me a little bit it depends depends it's
not so simple to save violence right
um but yes censorship is a good thing
but when done bad is a bad thing yeah uh
for instance uh Ian Crossland who is a
co-host on Tim cast IRL used to be a
moderator for minds.com and he had to
filter out graphic depictions of murder
and and rape and child abuse censorship
is absolutely vital in in that in that
regard so if we're talking about a book
like uh in particular there was one
called there's a teacher Who provided a
book to her middle schoolers called this
book is gay I don't know if you've ever
heard of it I have heard that's probably
a very good book and it provides
instruction on children she provided
instruction to children on how to use
adult gay anonymous sex amps yeah I
don't think that's appropriate now look
by all means you can be in favor of them
maybe maybe she had a child in her
classroom who wanted to go on Grindr and
have sex with adults is that your
argument no I mean I'm not saying that
first of all I don't know again this is
a 10 year old need grinder this is this
this is the thing that you do though
you're picking specific examples
I'm not in favor of censorship
this book is gay it's a book
that teaches the individual reading it
how to use adult sex apps and
holy crap there are things described in
that book that look you know
I can't even I can't even describe I'm
buying it I can't even bro you gotta
have it on the table oh you're buying
the book right I don't disagree with
that I don't like giving these people
money but I think it's important to know
and for people to read this stuff but
the book describes things that go well
beyond uh sex and kink into what I would
describe as dangerous behavior that can
result in serious uh
look when they talk about consuming
feces and there's and it goes beyond
that wow I'm like you're talking about
things that can cause serious harm to a
person let alone a child when she says
it's a great book and defends the idea
that children would get it I have to
wonder
I almost don't have to wonder it's a
question of do we really think these
people just don't know what they're
talking about or does she actually does
does Emma actually want children to have
sex with adults Emma had one thing on
her mind when she came in here and that
was disagree with Tim Poole there was
not any brain function going on she was
just what does Tim Poole say challenge
it because maybe maybe dude but she's an
idiot no no maybe but that's giving them
the benefit of the doubt when they're
trying to get kids on Grindr no no how
progressives view all of this right like
the patriarchy they want to tear all
that down but they they want to progress
beyond all institutions barriers they
think that laws that protect children
from sex is actually hurting them so
right it's causing them harm like that's
what the academics and ideologues of
progressivism believe yes Emma is not
that Emma is not like like she is not
she's like her head is so empty and that
like the whole point of her coming here
was to get something that and the same
thing goes for like the moon
Minority Report or whatever majority
report they're they're just they're just
looking to to to dunk on Tim pool she
came here hoping to get some kind of way
to dump dunk on Temple now you're right
there are people that know Theory and
actually believe it's good to to have
intergenerational uh relationships
people like Herbert Marcus and and you
know uh Gail Rubin I think is their name
and and the the people that write queer
Theory books you're totally right Emma's
not one of them Emma is a useful idiot
that's why she was was like screaming
about supporting
uh trans women in women's sports because
even if it hurts some of the competitors
you're saying you're saying I'm a Vega
lens advocacy for pedophilia isn't that
she herself is a pedophile but that she
stands opposed to yes like institutions
laws and and anything on the right
anything that comes out of your mouth
she's going to oppose she had no I will
say this the reason why I can't agree
with that
is you for what I don't want to give
them the benefit of the doubt because I
I think they know exactly what they're
talking about but for her maybe
she she did this thing where she after
the show she claimed she wasn't cool
enough to see the skate park it's the
weirdest thing in the world because I I
said earlier
maybe when she pulled up and parked she
didn't notice she was in a skate park
because the front of the property is the
skate park yeah and I'm like maybe she
they pulled up into the far space and
just walked right in the green room door
and she didn't notice because she didn't
look anywhere then I found out from
staff she was actually right in the
middle of it she she was standing in the
middle of the skate park there's ramps
everywhere there's rails and Ledges you
can see everything there's like a big
speaker for music and then she called
and said I didn't get to see the skate
park and I'm like that's a really weird
thing to lie about she wanted literally
the other one trip over the grinding
rail that is right at the front of the
house if you're not careful you will
fall over that she was talking about the
other skate park the downstairs one
that's what I think it was anyway I hear
dude downstairs is a mini ramp not a
skate park she was the skate park is the
is the is the the barn and the there's a
there's a massive 24 foot long vert wall
it's it's a it's a an eight-foot vert uh
eight foot wide vert and then there's a
20-foot or a 16 foot four uh four foot
section
you park right in front of it and you're
surrounded by ramps it's it's a weird
thing to lie about she could have said
well I did get I did get to see the
skate park I didn't get to see their
ramp though I could see how it might not
look like a skate park because there's a
bunch of cars parked all around it
because it's a parking lot as well it's
doubles as a parking lot you might not
have realized she was in one you're so
kind yeah she literally so she was
offered a tour Sushi and poker with the
boys when the show raped his head we're
all gonna hang out we're gonna we're
gonna uh we have sushi that's here
bubble tea cheeseburgers we put on some
music we got the table we play a micro
stakes poker game basically poker for
fun not for money and uh we can show you
around he goes no I can't I've got to
run and I'm like okay cool thanks for
coming and what does she do they
wouldn't show me anything well she
called Sam and they were they were
joking I mean she's pretty clear like
Tim this is like High School drama but I
think it was so that one but it wasn't
it was so that way she could slime the
like the people here yeah it wasn't it
wasn't like a haha Tim it wasn't a good
nature joke it wasn't because of because
she wanted to be humorous and and be fun
it was a way to slime Tim and her
experience here even though Tim was
polite kind and and that's not exactly
what Sam Cedar did exactly when we
invited him on the show I said I know
exactly what he's going to do it's low
tier WWE political garbage and if I
invite him on the show they do this
thing where all of a sudden abruptly
they'll say something in a a
non-sequitur and you're confused by what
they're saying because they she she had
on her computer I uh my understanding is
that she was being told what to say oh
really in the middle of the conversation
well she she had a list of things like
written out at your point that she's
like just vacuous yeah that's an
assumption man she's a journalist she
reads like 50 pages a day before she
works yeah look at look at what happened
with Stephen Crowder and Sam Cedar right
Stephen Crowder was gonna have a
conversation with Ethan Klein and then
Sam barges in and then starts just
clucking like a chicken like just bock
bock nonsense because it's WWE to them
so I'm like we can have her on the show
and I said it would be with another
person to discuss ideas we got Sean
Fitzgerald and what does she do before
the show we were like hey let's open
with crime and talk about Jordan
Williams this guy in New York who's you
know he was a black guy people are
saying he's not getting the same support
as uh uh Penny because he's black and
she goes yeah of course absolutely as
soon as the show starts what does she do
e-drama WWE garbage I think uh majority
report primarily is like a comedy show
slash it's more like The Daily Show like
that's it so let me let me finish please
uh and it's the whereas this shows more
serious and I think they both Sam and
Emma get get a kick out of making you
upset like it's just part of like the
pushing your friends around hold up this
is not no no I'm I'm stopping I'm sorry
this is not me being like oh I can't
believe I got dunked on it this is Emma
advocating for pedophilia no it's not
she's gonna cut her off at a minute and
five I was watching this clip I watched
the show live you cut her off at a
minute and five in the clip and didn't
let her talk about what she said maybe
the teacher has a student in her class
vets and you cut her off and that was
the end of it she couldn't explain
herself what watch the full episode I
did I watched it once yeah no she goes
into greater detail we talked for like
20 minutes about how she was like she
explicitly said she did not care if 10
year olds were shown I think
she's out of line she's not if you need
censorship for stuff that's an argument
they're having a show where they
advocate for pedophilia at a time where
they're chanting we're coming for your
children and they produced A 50-person
Chorus called we're coming for your
children Ian take the blinders off
that's what I'm saying I think there's a
blind there's blindness in people's
brains there where they think that
things have happened so slowly as
they're introducing sexuality to
Children nine-year-olds seeing porn and
things that now people are like why do
we censorship is the bad guy we don't
need just let things happen naturally
and like dude it's our duty and
responsibility to create a moral system
listen we don't stay on it every day
it's gonna go haywire when has the left
ever been against censorship
for her to be like I oppose censorship
it's like oh please they they complain
that someone says a naughty word on the
internet they want them all banned then
when it comes to the issue of pedophilia
she's like I think she I'm not even I'm
not even a quota when it comes to the
issue of pedophilia and a teacher trying
to get her to her students of 10 years
old to use grinder she defends it there
at hiroshikura said she would have said
okay like yes that's bad but here's what
I'm saying she didn't say that dude for
for two two and a half hours we talk or
like two hours and 20 minutes and she's
in every respect defending that they're
doing these things in every respect and
then they got to the point where I was
like I don't understand and it's
probably like Phil said whatever it is
we agree whatever it is we agree on no
matter what they oppose no matter what
so I'm like why I was like isn't it in
your interest to have Joe Biden like out
to get somebody else so when we come out
we're like hey here's evidence Joe
Biden's corrupt shouldn't you just be
like oh and she's like no it's not true
and I'm like oh wait wait what no it is
true reactionarianism you got to watch
out for that stuff anyone that's willing
to refute what you say because they
don't like you is a that's a big problem
that's what the left is right now a lot
of sides can can fall into that and I've
been explaining this for a while the
left as we describe it is a reactionary
movement what does that mean reactionary
doesn't mean you react to something it
is a specific reference to those who are
trying to bring back or preserve the old
ways that is what the left is doing when
they they're not about progress This Is
A Lie when when you get ibram candy
coming out and saying the only solution
to pass discrimination Etc et cetera
when he's basically advocating for
future discrimination
Derek uh Derek Bell I think I'm hoping
I'm not getting his name wrong they're
advocating for returning to Plessy V
Ferguson they want to bring back the old
before the Civil Rights Movement they
are reactionaries who are upset we had a
civil libertarian revolution in this
country that brought about individual
rights they are collectivists they hate
that we've enshrined in our constitution
individual rights and they want to turn
back the clock to get rid of that
they're reactionaries now you're right
as for Emma maybe it is fair to say no
matter what it is you advocate for she
will be against if I say hey look here's
evidence Joe Biden corruption I'm like
but you hate you it's personal Tim it
was all about like there after it was
personal about you that I mean anybody
that was here obviously would have been
a representative of Tim Cass but like
the whole thing was they want Clips they
were hoping to get Clips but Emma was
just incapable of producing something
that would be compelling for them other
than oh he didn't show me his uh his his
skate park I wonder if they feel I I
kind of felt like Emma felt a little bit
of shame because I know that the thing
she said about Neo-Nazi she was told to
say probably by Sam and afterwards when
the Show wrapped you know and she steps
out of the room for a bit we are all
talking about it about this is the issue
with the majority report the Sam Cedar
is blacklisted from a bunch of big
networks and podcasts he got fired from
MSNBC I think I think and this is
explicitly why as has been iterated to
me by a lot of people that he's an
unserious person who just tries to
gamify people for for bad faith politics
and then you know as she's walking back
in the room uh Sean was like oh the
Neo-Nazi thing is out of line it's like
it's not a real debate it's not a real
political argument it's just an
intentionally destructive to the
political space and then she like is
looking down she wouldn't look as look
as in the eyes at all the whole time I
wonder like she had made a big stink
about uh the amount of money that they
don't make and didn't want to admit that
it's because there's not really an
audience for it or not the same kind of
audience
um she did mention like you'd said
earlier one of the things that I wanted
to push back on she said over and over
that she was covering serious political
topics and et cetera
um and I think that all all of the
majority report and her in particular
but I would assume that the feeling is
shared with most of the people over
there is just massive jealousy they
don't get invited up to Capitol Hill
they're not they're not streaming their
show from Congress you know from
congressional people's offices they're
not they don't have the same kind of uh
reach they don't get the same kind of
reaction uh from from audiences and
stuff so I think but that's that you're
right but that's like saying the people
who intentionally choose not to shower
are surprised that people don't want
them around absolutely and that's
exactly how people behave I've smelled
plenty of stinky people like they people
get people don't know that their breath
stinks or that they're that they're
offensive to other people that their
ideas are or they they behave in ways
that you know push people away if people
realize that there probably wouldn't be
any incel she was saying that they that
Sam is like a comedian first he's not
really his primary focus is in business
jokes too what they need you what they
need is a 10 a month subscription like
they need to load because they've got
1.3 million subscribers or something
majority report those like you guys can
monetize big time get 20 000 subscribers
a month 15 000 whatever you know you're
gonna be you're gonna be fine you know I
enjoy telling people that they did that
it was about the politics and it wasn't
for money and da da da da she loved like
she was reveling in pointing out that
she was morally Superior that was one of
the things that was really so gross
about it she came here and and had this
air of superiority and we're better than
you and we're blah blah blah just and it
was just I found it you know you know
what I think the majority report I think
they're like the the incel equivalent of
politics
where like
you get you get a guy who's out of shape
not really not doesn't have good social
skills says crude and rude things smells
bad and has a poor diet and then they
get really jealous that people don't
want to be friends with them so they go
online they get really angry and start
talking about how the world sucks and
how bad it is
and I think that's what the majority
report is because you know you can have
you have this big political space with a
whole bunch of different commentators of
different various backgrounds all having
debates and you know and getting along
to varying degrees and then you have the
majority report where Sam gets like
banned from a bunch of different shows
then complains about it and then when
people bring up that he's banned they
wouldn't Emma say she's like well it's
because they're scared of them it's like
part of it and because he's a dick she
was no one's scared of him dude it's
probably both it's literally not it's
because well Destiny is he's straight
upset if there's anyone on the left I
would that's fine if Destiny said that
but but and I and I think Sean mentioned
that but I can tell you this
definitively because I've talked to many
prom like many big networks and stuff
they've explicitly said they think he's
just gonna come and and clown them like
he's not he's not a real he's not a
serious person it's a clown show it's
it's the you know the WWE of of politics
you're gonna get this phase he was an
actor I mean he's an actor he's a
comedian funny actor he was an actor for
years but like at least Jon Stewart
actually would would address things
you know yeah John's pretty awesome was
unique dude was and now he's doing the
same thing
but let's let's move on let's move on
and talk about uh where we're going with
get well go bro because we have this
story from CNN business this is great
from last Friday
Starbucks workers at 150 stores go on
strike over Pride decorations that's
right ladies and gentlemen they said
that there was no policy to take down
Pride decorations and then 150 United
Starbucks stores in the United States
went on strike on Friday I think I said
about 3 500 employees will be on strike
and I believe we have from the
post-millennial
Starbucks Union boasts they closed 21
locations last weekend in response to
the alleged lgbtq Pride decoration bin
I think it's fair to say it's not
alleged the workers at these stores said
they weren't allowed to put up
decorations I don't care what corporate
is saying the people are that they're
actually protesting here's what I think
Evan I think Starbucks said outright
we're gonna lose a bunch of money shut
it down and the workers protested I
think that what we're seeing now is as I
mentioned earlier in the show
the Bud Light effect shows
get will go broke but also anti-woke
equals clicks and so you're seeing a lot
of apolitical people now coming out and
being like Oh yeah yeah I don't like Bud
Light because they know they're going to
get a million hits if they do it
Starbucks was just like we better get
out of this one just take it down and
now their employees are revolting
well they're they're employees are in
Revolt that's absolutely revolting yeah
it is funny how that word goes into two
directions no there's their employees
are in Revolt at many locations because
this is what happens big corporations
know
look
we're gonna we're in the members only
section we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna play the video of the guy
doing something in front of children
like I got to be very careful I didn't
want to explain it spreading himself and
you know it's it's it's a horrifying in
public and I I would normally like to
challenge YouTube and be like hey
YouTube Here's a video from pride in
public with children certainly you can't
have a problem with that right but I I
know that there's a line we've we did it
before with one video because I'm like I
don't think YouTube would take this down
they didn't this one I'm like they're
gonna take it down there's there's
videos of explicit nudity and it's it's
like with with these books like
genderqueer when parents tried to rate
it to the school board meeting they get
banned from it but the kids are reading
it so
you know anyway my point is we'll show
that in the members only section but I
think what's happening is when you see
an old man uh when you see a guy in a
diaper and a dog mask running up to your
kids turning around and wiggling his
butt at them parents are starting to go
like hey hold on there a minute when you
get the video of the guy with the Bugs
Bunny mask fully nude and then jumping
up and down and shaking his his genitals
in front of in front of people and their
kids at this event regular people go yo
hold on there a minute then Starbucks
comes out and says we love it and they
go I ain't going to Starbucks anymore
Bud Light is the perfect example of it
Smackdown no longer the top here in the
country and all these corporations fear
it
it's the hubris right it's the pride
like they think they can get away with
acting in a revolting manner right like
this is actually disgusting Behavior
that's repulsive to normal everyday
people even it's even repulsive to
people that are part of the LGBT
community I I that's why it's fracture
that's why you're getting fracturing
groups like uh gays against groomers and
all that and then get the L Out quote
get the L out and quote is the name of
an organization it's uh lesbians who
don't want to be associated with what's
going on I love it but yeah we need to
see more of that it's it they're they're
dividing all of our factions and now
that it's coming home to roost and but
they can't there's going to be continued
it's going to continue to get more and
more extreme and there will be more
pushbacks like this is going to hurt
Starbucks I don't know how long I don't
know how badly it's not going to be the
target problem but I I don't get it I
mean Starbucks is a pretty gay friendly
company uh the idea that they're not gay
enough is kind of a weird argument I
don't think any of these companies care
you know people talk about ESG and CEI
or whatever and I'm like they just want
look when there was no pushback
companies were like how much will it
cost to do a pride month thing it'll
cost five grand for the decorations and
what's our upside oh we'll be involved
in this big celebration and then we'll
maybe see a bump in sales now there's
pushback now they say yeah it'll cost
you five grand to do and you'll lose
three hundred thousand dollars per
location because people will boycott
your store and they'll like pull the
decorations they don't actually care
it's all about the path of least
resistance and the fact that regular
people are providing resistance these
companies are immediately just changing
course
the regular people thing matters a lot
like I said uh I mean I've said this
before on the show I was just in
California doing some more ATR stuff
last couple weeks and some of my friends
out there like you talk to him about
this stuff and and they're like look I
got kids and I'm a progressive guy and
stuff but man that ain't right but I
don't want to do this and they really
understood the the ramifications of
having you know their kids be exposed to
this stuff and I think that the average
person is is rejecting it out of hand I
think that the normal people that are
again you know have maybe 15 20 minutes
a week for politics that's all they
spend on on knowing what's going on in
the world you know they they maybe they
see some memes that their friends send
and then they'll listen to you know the
news for 15 minutes the in the evening
or whatever or in the morning those
people are the ones that are like yo I
don't like the idea of the teacher
wanting my child to transition
you know I watched The Passion of the
Christ for the first time
wow I heard it's gruesome it is it's
really and um
the beginning I thought was a little
slow and then it actually got really
really good it's not uh I wouldn't
describe it as explicitly religious I
mean obviously it is but what I mean is
it's political in another the reason I
bring this up is someone's just to
mention because of all this there's
going to be a far right backlash and
then I saw that I thought to myself I'm
like well I did just watch the passion
for the first time ever because I was I
was curious I'm like you know I grew up
Catholic not Christian not real but I do
now want to understand more so what the
points that are being made so I did
watch it and uh it was it was it's it's
it's actually pretty good I do think you
know
there needs to be a movie for the
average person this one was in Aramaic
Hebrew and Latin with subtitles hard to
watch but the reason I bring it up is I
learned a lot that I didn't know even
having gone to Catholic School
that changed my perspective on some of
these issues
and I think part it is partly due to
what we are seeing from the left that I
was open to having watched a movie like
that again I'm not a Christian I do
believe in God I don't believe in the
Christian like the Catholic church or
anything like that
but it got me watching this and learning
about Pontius Pilate and um what was the
name at the murderer who was released
and all this stuff Barabbas and all this
stuff things I didn't know that you know
the Pontius was like I can release one
person Jesus or Barabbas the murderer
and they're like release the murderer
like that's how much they hate him see
you went to Catholic school and they
didn't cover this nope that is
incredible but that may be why there's a
break in religion
they said they filled the crowd with
people that were like get Jesus I think
they had false Flags I think they had
like yeah that's right I don't want to
talk I'm not trying to stop so we can
talk about religion my point was simply
I do believe there will be a pendulum
swing towards the right because of this
I think what's happening now is people
are starting to ask questions of how to
get to the point where there are
pedophiles shaking their genitals in
front of children and thrusting and you
know towards them while they watch and
it's like well I don't think it's it
completely correlates with with religion
but the pendulum will swing people will
look back at where we were 10 years ago
and say what were we doing back then
it's like oh okay we had standards the
standards were like this you're going to
hear arguments from people who are
Christian who are Catholic and they're
going to say here's what we believe and
why we oppose it and then you're going
to get regular moms and dads who are
like what do I have to do to stop the
man from gyrating nude in front of my
children and the left is going to say
you're a bigot and the right is going to
say church is this way there's already
people that are starting to talk about
you know Christian nationalism and stuff
and that's the the too far swing back to
the right and like people like James
Lindsay thankfully are already like
looking for ways to push back against
them because there is going to be an a
reaction from the right there's way more
people going to church now than there
were probably five years ago there's way
more young people converting or
rediscovering religion in response to
what they're seeing as what they would
consider uh perversion or whatever or
what is it what's the word they like to
use deviancy or whatever um but it's
something that liberals and again normal
liberals not
progressives it's something that
liberals have to be aware of and have to
be be concerned with because you don't
want to allow the government to have too
much influence by the Christian right
like
a liberal Society can make room for the
Christian right it can make room for
progressives it can make room for for
Muslims it can make room for everybody
if you have a liberal society that
doesn't favor one ideology right now our
liberal Society is heavily influenced
and heavily favors Progressive ideology
and we I think it's really important to
not allow the pendulum to swing back and
I know if Sheamus were here he'd be
screaming at me but I really do think
that it's important to not let the
pendulum swing back too far so make a
little bit yes definitely well you know
to the point where we're not like
genitals off of little kids isn't that
funny though that it was the kids like
they couldn't avoid going the kids route
because that's I think where it all
shifted was when the American people saw
just how much was aimed at our kids
there's two right in schools and and on
TV and and just all of this stuff the
surgeries all that stuff the kids were
the final straw it started kind of with
the women's sports issue right that was
released first started to see a big push
back they had to go for the kids yeah
because as we've talked about quite a
bit the the birth rates among those of
the liberal worldview are substantially
lower than those of conservatives and so
the saying goes socialists don't have
kids they have yours but it's not
working the parental rights and
education stuff the reason why Emma had
to defend a genderqueer and this book is
gay is because the left needs to
indoctrinate kids and break them from
their families grooming is one way to do
it they they here's what happens they
need to create a rift between parents
and kids to such a degree that the kids
run away from home it really is a crazy
thing right so I'll give you an example
one of the things we talked about on the
culture War podcast was desistance rates
if a child is gender dysphoric
desistance is when they stop being
dysphoric and there have been a couple
studies that we've cited these are the
cited studies as it pertains to
resistance 61 to 95 or is it 98 uh I
think it's like 96 or it's it's around
there it's in the Heights 90 so let's
say the lowest number 61 to 61 percent
of children suffering gender dysphoria
who receive no intervention desist
that is the majority if we're trying to
do the max amount of good taking a
utilitarian perspective well then we
would lean towards not intervening and
giving medical treatment or sex changes
to kids
she advocated for it despite the fact it
would result in more suicide and more
depression why it's the only way they
can get new recruits to their cult
if children are raised by conservative
parents and conservative households and
conservative communities those kids will
be conservative they need to find a way
to rip those kids from the parents and
they found a way
so if you look at it this way
if 61 percent of kids desist
with no intervention and they go on to
lead normal lives
that would mean the suicidal ideation
drops dramatically with no intervention
if you intervene
they say that does detransition is
almost non-existent among those that are
put on puberty blockers however going
from the natural rates of desistence and
looking at the percentage of trans
people who who commit suicide which is
which is sad and horrifying we don't
want that to happen
if they take if they take 10 kids
who are gender dysphoric and on the high
end nine out of ten will desist
that means they are taking nine kids and
increasing the risk of suicide among
those kids by something like 50 percent
if they do nothing those nine kids will
not see an increased suicide rate
because there's an increased suicide
rate amongst people who are gender
dysphoric
so when they advocate for giving
intervention to kids who would otherwise
be better they are advocating for
increasing the risk to Suicide that's
why my view is we should not be doing
this I don't care what the AMA says or
whatever but again the point is it
doesn't matter to them because they need
to find a way to rip kids from their
families both Stalin and Hitler made
comments about if you get control of the
children it doesn't matter what the
parents think it's something that is
baked into socialist ideology because
they want because they want to change
society they don't like the liberal
society that we live in and unhappy
people be can be made into
revolutionaries happy people that have
happy families they are not looking to
revolt so the left the Revolutionary
left unquestionably wants miserable
people with destroyed lives so that way
they can make them into activists happy
people don't Revolt you're not going to
get a revolution when most people are
happy that's the biggest problem that
Herbert Marquis found with with
capitalism he was like look capitalism
delivers the goods so we have to find
other unhappy people because capitalism
has made the proletariat mostly happy
mostly successful they have a good life
Tim could I reiterate something that
your whole point about them ripping the
kids away from the parents that is the
entire point and you need to look no
further than their next steps that
they're already working towards right so
like uh the last year and a half two
years we've gotten 19 states to ban
these treatments and puberty blockers
for kids 19 right we need all 50 sex
changes child sex changes
where the blue states are going now
because they know the desistance rates
what they're doing is they're doing
trans trafficking bills right where
basically if the kid if you're on
vacation right and you're in um what
Washington State California or Minnesota
now and you are there and your kid calls
CPS or whatever calls the cops the state
can actually take your kids away from
you and put you in a foster it's worse
than that
your 13 year old kid is surfing on the
internet and goes on Tick Tock gets
exposed to the likes of Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney Advocates these children
drink alcohol haha it's so much fun
drink beer beer is fun
advocates for many of a lot of these
ideas kid gets confused
the kid says I can't talk to my parents
because people online are telling me
that my parents will get mad at me then
someone messages them and says if you
want I can drive you to Washington
stranger on the internet drives the kid
to Washington and says we saved them and
the state says yup you sure did
an internet stranger can kidnap your
child have them sterilized in another
state and that state says it's legal yep
but it's kidnapping in the state
I would imagine that and do you think
Joe Biden's doj would go after the
person who did the kidnapping takes the
FBI they won't do it
of course they won't I would doubt it I
hope they would but I mean come on the
NYPD
they didn't arrest any of these people
who are thrusting in front of children
they are a protected class but that's
what everyone's ignoring support it
right the cops in New York this is the
funny thing about back the blue and all
that stuff I'm like you realize the the
left BLM they're protesting Democrat
cops and Democrat cities I don't care
about them like good I'll look when they
come out they say do you find the place
I'm like yes please do so now don't come
to my where I live in deep on the police
our cops are good because we live in in
modern country and our cops are manga
cops so like they don't allow us now to
be fair
we do have I was talking about this
earlier Jefferson County which is
Harper's Ferry has banned children being
a part of drag shows as it's adult and
sexually explicit but uh Berkeley County
doesn't and recently in Martinsburg uh
West Virginia they had a drag show where
they invited children up on stage and
this is a dude wearing like like it
overtly sexual stuff like it is
I would call it overtly sexual but not
sexually explicit is a fair way to put
it I would call it grooming
introducing
Kink and foreplay to children that's
basically what they're doing
they did not get arrested and that's in
West Virginia so you still have their
problems but these cops in New York this
has been going on for decades these New
York cops like it they're a part of it
they're there watching it happen going
yeah
do you think that there's anyone there
that is a I mean I'm sure there's like a
few that are against it but like play it
out no absolutely not 100 of the NYPD I
don't think they've game planned it and
on the NYPD I love it love well you saw
the San Francisco cops right like
they're marching in doing the whole
pride flag NYPD took a knee for BLM okay
you you listen
you can tell me that you you think
probably deep down inside they're
they're disturbed by what they had to do
but I'm kind of like listen man actions
speak louder than words if if someone
told you to like sniff durian you'd be
like no it's disgusting right
if you're like oh man I really don't
want to but let me get in there and
sniff it I'm gonna be like come on you
want to and like no they're making me if
you really didn't want to do it you
wouldn't do it now there is obviously
there's Nuance in all this and there are
certain things people don't want to do
they they do but I'm kind of like look
man if you were in the NYPD if you're in
New York and you know there are adult
men pedophiles thrusting their genitals
in front of children and you're like
leave me out of that at least I can say
you're okay with it the NYPD these
officers are okay with what's going on
the funny thing is there's a story about
a woman who goes around New York topless
and cops will arrest her for it and then
she sues them and wins because it is
legal to be topless for women in New
York City where are these cops during
these events where these people are
breaking the law explicitly they don't
care because the very least I can say
they may say they don't like it fine but
they are okay with it me I'm not I'm not
okay with it yeah no I don't want to
live in a place like that no
hierarchy
some it's it's it's a dual uh
application of the law it's it's
it's not the same thing but it's the
same attitude that people have when it
comes to all the way up to the president
and the president's kid you know the
Democrats can get away with breaking the
law can get away with doing uh you know
what would be illegal for you or me and
the reason is because of political
opinions it always has been yeah the j6
people are still in jail for trespassing
did you know uh I I could be wrong about
this but we've been doing our research
and in West Virginia it is illegal to
cohabitate if you're not married really
what I'm pretty sure the law I like I
don't know if there's been any rulings
on it but the law stance you can look
look you can pull it up right now I
think it's like chapter 61 or something
West Virginia a criminal code
and the law just says what it says it
may be that there's a precedent where
that nullified it or something but I'm
I'm like the law is still there nobody
enforces it that would be insane I think
Massachusetts still has laws on the
books that they called blue laws back in
that were from back in the day things
like you're not allowed to have your
store open on Sunday right and I don't
know if they're if they're still on the
books but when I was a kid uh they were
still on the books and jokes because you
know imagine being a devout Catholic
angry that people are violating the
Sabbath and you're like these these
liberals came in and got the cops to
stop enforcing the Sabbath law and and
there you go progress it's likely that
this particular topic will not have the
same effect as violating the Sabbath
just because there is well going after
kids is different from having from
having a job on Sundays exactly you know
between that or or whether it be uh the
lacks prosecution of people that commit
violent crimes in in cities and stuff
like that that stuff has a a direct
result that people really are gonna
notice yeah did you find the law yeah
but it's it's a kind of wordy there's an
absence divorce and void marriage uh
section there's also a bigamy section I
like the the law the first paragraph is
like you shall not cohabitate if not
married if you're uh any person being
married who during the life of the
former let's see this is a little child
no you're reading a different law okay
then this would be this is 61 uh point
eight I think is the one you were yeah
there's one specifically about
cohabitation without marriage or
whatever but my point is in New York
they don't enforce these laws because it
is social socially acceptable in New
York to do these things no we're talking
about reaction reactionism to the
pendulum swinging and if it could swing
back hard in the other direction
inadvertently I think the two things
that really get my gut where I'm like
wow I could see myself freaking out and
becoming one of those pendulum things if
I didn't have my head on straight is
going after children with sex and store
violence people people breaking into
stores and just robbing the shelves I'm
like yo when aren't they armed aren't
these stores like do they have armed
defense like uh oh yeah I think my
camera might no no we're opening the
door oh because there's no point to wait
the door's gonna be open yeah because
the AC is busted all right
um it's like 80 something 83 or 84
degrees in here now and I'm like okay we
gotta open the door I've had like three
of these liquid deaths
like when I finally I describe it yeah
when I find myself wondering like why
don't why aren't these shopkeepers armed
the three dudes walk in and they all
have guns on with them and I'm like the
shopkeepers just him versus a bunch of
gun armed dudes like it makes me want
the shopkeeper to be armed and then I'm
like hoping he's able to defend himself
and it's like that I don't want to want
that but I'm that's what I want when I
see these people breaking and destroying
businesses I want these people their
owners to survive what's that you want
order yeah I do want to order that's the
that's the impulse that ends up having
the right come in into place because
Baron Trump is going to be like this
brutal I mean dictator have you ever
seen the red caesar no have you seen the
picture from the Denver Airport of the
kid with the iron fist you know I'm
talking about these these conspiracy
paintings from Denver for sure let me
pull up these conspiracy theory
paintings Denver paintings
I'll show you man it's all it's all been
pre-planned where's it where are these
pictures Baron Trump is man I'm kidding
by the way but I do want to show you
these pictures I mean you you could be
kidding but at the same time you know
the Simpsons were kidding a lot and then
stuff happened so you know so like there
are these creepy paintings that people
always talk about it's like there's like
a Nazi officer stabbing the dub of peace
or whatever and people are cowering and
crying and then there's like the Earth
being destroyed and animal like a
penguin box yeah it's like because I've
gone extinct here's one it's it's like
new age like Lefty religious iconography
yeah and then there's uh where's the
iron fist one there's a kid let me let
me look this up
see it's gnosticism where's the kid
iron Marvel stuff comes up there's a a
kid raising a I don't know where it is
is this one it
uh yeah okay there it is there it is you
can't really see him it's a German kid
it looks like and he's got an Iron Fist
and he's raising it up for peace or
whatever anyway I'm kidding but like
you know that's the joke that it's gonna
be like 10 or it's gonna be like 20 or
30 years and baron Trump is gonna like
he's gonna hey we're gonna bring order
and he gets elected and he's the
dictator
scary but I mean I really don't think
Barron Trump's going to be president or
anything like that I'm just kidding I
would like to meet him so if you go the
Atlantic is Baron though the Atlantic
ran this article in 1926 and you can
find the actual copy of it but it was
about the dissolution of marriage and
the abolition of family in the Soviet
Union they like they had a reporter go
over and she went to all these little
towns they basically made marriage
dissolution a five-minute process no
fault anyone could go in they didn't
Reagan do that yeah that's right he did
he was one of the I think they were the
first state in California uh that's
exactly right so in this article it is
it has stories from the villagers who
are saying this is insane what was
happening is these guys would go and
they'd knock up these women after
marrying them and then they just abandon
them and you would have these entire
towns and cities being ransacked by
these criminal orphans right and kind of
like what's happening now exactly
exactly we this is exactly what we're
going through it's been a longer process
in the United States I mean we've had
what no fault divorce for 70 years about
um but this is exactly what was no it
was in like the 50s and 60s when they
started doing like striking it down
through the courts I think but it was
Reagan who explicitly got rid of no
fault divorce
but he was it was he did it when he was
governor of California I think I don't
think there was a federal dissolution of
marriage act I think the state started
doing it but it's exactly what we're
going through right now and it's so
crazy
whoa none of that none of the the ideas
that come from the left are
significantly different than any of the
ideas that were coming from the left a
hundred years ago they're just dressed
differently instead of having uh
bourgeoisie and the proletariat now
they've they've made it more more like
the Nazis didn't it's all race-based and
stuff now but it the ideas and the the
prescriptions are still the same the the
Socialist ideal is to remake man so that
way man desires to be a social animal a
socialist in his very core but do they
don't they see that stripping the family
apart is bad for the kids and therefore
bad for the society they do not because
if all of your family is Humanity
because you're a socialist you don't
need a mom and a dad because all of the
adults have the correct socialist
opinions that they can just pass on to
the children and then the children will
teach the adults and the adults will
teach the children children we talked
about this on the culture more podcasts
when we are we're talking about Zach
Voorhees on AI and stuff and the way I
described it was think about the human
body
there are single-celled organisms all
over everything
those little single-celled organisms are
little individuals that run around doing
little who knows what
then you get multi-celled organisms the
human body has a whole bunch of cells
they all must do their job what do you
call a cell in the human body that
deviates from its job cancer cancer and
what does the body do to things that
deviate from their prescribed drop drop
beat them destroys them sometimes it
does not and the cancer eventually
destroys the body and ends it
the way I would describe the modern left
is they want to create a human
civilization that functions much in this
way in that you will be born and given
your task and you will never deviate or
else
they want to turn the human system of
individuals into an organism system
where everyone functions much like a
cell and does their assigned job period
and with genetic modification and
engineering crispr and all that stuff
you'll get to the point where you will
have bread enforcers like China's doing
the super soldiers you will have bread
miners bread analysts you'll be born
it's like the plot of Man of Steel yeah
have you guys you've seen that where on
Krypton they evolve to the point where
they started genetically engineering
people for their specific jobs and he
was you know um
they say that Superman is the first
natural birth in like 100 years or
whatever and then zad is like blasphemy
that's the world they want to create
oh you will you will be a white blood
cell your job is to eliminate free
radicals and Intruders and you will
never be anything else your job is the
red blood cell you will carry the oxygen
you will oxidize et cetera et cetera
they will give you your task and you
will never deviate that's not good
because diversity is one of our
strengths even on an individual level
man you're supposed to be able to be an
astronaut and a musician and a teacher
like all those things you're able you
can do all that stuff that's that it
never ever works out like that like the
the idea that once you get to the
Socialist Utopia you can you know do
your slam poetry and and be an artist no
get in the mine they're the free
radicals yeah they would call themselves
free radicals hey I can confirm 50 years
ago as 54 uh no fault divorce 1969 in
California Ronald Reagan signed the
first note divorce statue right I
thought it was I thought it was then I
guess he did it again when he was
president nationally is that the story
uh I don't know I don't think he did I
don't think there's anything nationally
I think it's just like the courts all
started striking it down a lot like the
the gay marriage progress now in all 50
states there's no fault divorce so we
reverse the snowfall divorce thing yes
absolutely
this is this is what I was describing I
said how about we do this you can keep
your no fault divorce but we'll create
something called super marriage where if
you agree to First you get married once
you're married you can then upgrade to
the courts to a super marriage and you
can't break a super marriage sorry it's
till death do us part so in in Louisiana
we're trying to figure out how to solve
this too Louisiana has something called
uh Covenant marriage and it's it's not
like what you just described we're like
you could upgrade your marriage you
either enter into like a state marriage
a government marriage or you enter into
a covenant marriage and it's no it's not
about you don't abide by no fault
divorce but the numbers for it are not
impressive and so there needs to be more
like a marketing campaign for it I need
to look more into it to be honest I
don't know if they've tried to Market it
but you would think that like women
would demand that their husband or their
fiance enters into that extra protection
of marriage but I I don't know marriage
today has been downgraded to dating yeah
it's like Disney it's like you see these
celebrities like they're married for a
year I'm like bro what's the point of
saying till death do us part if you
actually mean like we'll see how it goes
garbage yeah marriage doesn't exist no
fault divorce ended marriage now we have
something we call marriage but there's
no marriage and surprise surprise we're
heading direction to the Soviets yep
slower you know because we do have
protections from the Constitution and
things like that but it's happening
absolutely
uh yeah aspects of it I guess but I mean
but yeah we're it's not like we're just
in the Soviet Union it never just
happens overnight it's it's slowly and
incremental oh speaking of this Russian
Revolution that was happening apparently
that was like I think they both realized
this is when uh what's his name uh the
Putin's best friend of 23 years who was
running the The Mercenaries turned on
Moscow and they're like oh he's going
over through the country it's gonna be
another Russian Revolution like 1917 and
I think they both realized that and
we're like we got to call this thing off
I thought they were I heard they were
going to disband the mercenary group and
that's why they revolved it and then
like no okay we're not going to disband
you it could be all fake news I don't
know but they're afraid of another
Russian Revolution that's
at least it seemed like it were you
sayful I'm afraid I mean I don't know
but I think that the
I think the United States not doing
something had there been actual conflict
between Wagner and and state forces I
think that would have drawn the U.S into
some kind of or at least made the neocon
say look we really need to get some kind
of uh some kind of boots on the ground
to control the situation because of the
fact that they have so many nuclear
weapons and the United States would feel
like we need to control that I think the
United States as an institution that's
not an endorsement either is Swiss
cheese
it is
I I imagine a piece of paper in which
several points of it have been lightly
ignited and are just burning to Embers
from the inside out
the fact that we have this conflict in
Eastern Europe that makes literally no
sense for the most part it's a failed
liberal economic order led by the U.S
and Western Powers that's failing and
makes no sense struggling the fact that
Donald Trump even got elected shows that
the Deep State you know permanent
Government powers that be have failed
their the children who inherited this
machine don't know how to run it the
fact that you have this Bolshevik style
family destruction happening in this
country all of the institutions of this
country are crumbling including the
military the foreign empirical
structures and all that stuff and I'm
just like you know that's what I think a
lot of these leftists want they want it
to just crumble and collapse I'm sure
Russia and China are happy to see it
happen as well and are probably Fanning
the Flames online Tick-Tock I think
intentionally does this and it's
annoying to me when I see these
Republicans being like we should ban
Tick Tock for diet for data privacy
concerns and I'm like no you should do
it because they're indoctrinating your
kids to self-harm and it's horrifying
they always do that though like the the
Republicans will like look at the
national debt debate right they they
talk about fiscal sanity and fiscal
responsibility we've had trillion dollar
deficits for what's it's Bill Clinton I
think you know that was the first time
if you want to cut the deficit you want
to cut the debt start arguing in terms
of morality argue against how these
programs that we're funding are killing
the country and how how it's hurting us
like that is the way to do it that's
exactly right tick tock is bad because
it's hurting our kids not because
they're taking our data no one cares
about that it's too like esoteric or or
Niche yep we don't no one knows for sure
if it's what they're doing that's the
big problem no we do know for sure it's
all uh it's explicit that they're doing
it well it's it's inductive like we
don't have access to the code so we
can't verify that it's intentionally
doing it it might just be they could be
like the outcome I said they are doing
it
Tick Tock is I guess that's true and to
be fair like to extent YouTube as well
but Tick Tock being the worst and being
owned by our foreign principal for a
principal foreign adversary uh
indirectly I mean but basically yes it
is so they they they promote videos that
cause kids to to self-harm like it could
be a Thing Worth and they ban they they
ban uh people who who push back against
it it could be like and I think it is
nefarious personally I think that
they're using it like a fifth
generational Warfare tactic but it could
be the kind of thing where like if I'm
dropping rocks on the ground and then
they're rolling down the hill and you're
like Ian's Rolling Hills down the ground
and I don't even realize that I'm just
dropping the Rocks they just happen to
be rolling yes Ian so you're on top of a
hill and you were throwing rocks down it
it doesn't matter what your intention is
exactly I don't know what their
intention is stop you from doing it I I
assume and I assume their intention is
that they want to corrupt the uh the
Youth of the United States and the rest
of the globe to fall in line with
Chinese economics that is my I think
they want the US to crumble well the
tick tock's different in China isn't it
I
it's a similar but different thing yeah
it's like Sesame Street though like for
kids like they have like educational
stuff it's a little exaggerated when
people say like theirs is perfect and
ours is bad they don't have Tick Tock
they have a different company that does
something similar they have their own
version of it but they they they own
hours and hours as weaponized against us
has been weaponized to cause us harm
so but mostly yes yeah
yeah and that's why it should be banned
but anyway Republicans are mostly
controlled opposition so what do I what
do I ultimately think is where we're
headed for I think the US's position as
the leader of the liberal economic order
or the you know the global economic
order whatever they want to call it it's
going to be over
I think the U.S will probably go back to
more humble routes it's a simple way to
put it I don't see the system being
sustainable it's about to collapse I'm
not saying your life will end and the
world will burst into flames I'm saying
probably don't want to be in a city
probably want to get a nice little piece
of land with some chickens or something
on it some goats maybe have a little
garden
because uh good luck there's you're in a
city there's a lot of uh
um a lot of countries that are moving
away from the dollar that are looking to
buy oil in other forms of currency and
stuff and I think that that's probably
the most Salient uh evidence that the
United States has lost its or at least
the dollars lost its luster that people
are people around the globe are looking
to move away from alliances with the US
and you know you can point to any number
of of political Follies that the
government has has engaged in in the
past 15 20 years but
if the dollar is not the reserve
currency then the value of the dollar
that we is going to be you know
destroyed because not just because of
how many print how many we print it up
but because we're no longer the country
that maintains hegemony throughout the
world yeah Alex we're actually we're
going to talk about Alex Jones I just
saw on the next clip but he was on
Patrick Bet David's show and was talking
about like this war in Russia or this
this revolution potentially going on in
Russia where they're pregosian I think
is the name of the guy who runs uh what
is it Wagner Wagner group and he was
like well I don't need he asked them
genuinely like would we be better off if
some new regime took over in Russia that
was sympathetic to the west and they
didn't have an answer but I thought yes
we wouldn't be killing each other
anymore but it would become techno
fascism way more rapidly like they want
a peaceful world where people are
plugged into machines they don't want
fighting they don't want killing they
don't want blowing up they want everyone
to be subservient as much as possible
and I think it would be better than
Warfare it might be the next step of our
Evolution but it might also just become
a pressure cooker let's let's jump to
this next story from timgas.com yeah
Alex Jones says deep state will try to
assassinate former president Donald
Trump radio show says that corrupt
government actors will never allow Trump
to make good and a promise to prosecute
them for their criminal activity you
want to know I found this so interesting
is that RFK Jr said something similar
recently said that he has to be aware of
what they did to his uncle and and his
dad right yeah and so he's like it's a
very real possibility
if we've got we've come to a point
call it whatever you want believe
whatever you want to believe the left
can say far right conspiracy theory
whatever it's come to the point where
high profile Personalities in this
country including one presidential
Contender himself RFK are are afraid
that there is a potential assassination
looming for two different prominent high
profile contenders and dare I say Front
Runners when we're talking about like
let's say the top five candidates who
could win RFK Jr they may call him
Fringe they may say it's never gonna
happen but he's polling really well and
so he's certainly pulling better than
any other Republican outside of trump
and DeSantis and I think he's got more
favorability than all other candidates
now you got Alex Jones saying this a lot
of people will say oh but Alex Jones is
crazy and I'm like listen
we know that they're going to try to Pro
I'm sorry try to they're literally
Prosecuting Trump I don't know about
going this far but it's been said by
other people and it's been said before
and if RFK is saying something similar
himself
it just I don't know it speak to the
times does it speak to the times that
we're in that we're at this point I was
just talking about how the institution
of this country is Swiss cheese like the
fabric of this nation is being burned
out from the inside and it's and it's
fumbling and breaking apart did you
could you have ever believed
10 years ago that we'd get to a point
where a contender for the presidency
would say he fears assassination and
when there's actual talk in the
political space among high-profile shows
of a of the former president who was
running potentially being assassinated
like people wouldn't believe you if you
said that's where we'd be
you mentioned or maybe you would I don't
know you mentioned uh earlier the left
talk having a problem with this the left
should not be or is in no position to
make comments about whether or not the
CIA will or will not do something
because the CIA has been the boogeyman
of the left for literally ever if you
ask anyone that's an actual leftist why
socialism has not taken hold globally it
is going to be the CIA that's what
they're gonna say they're gonna blame
CIA they do it all the time so
the idea that that the left would reject
a conspiracy theory about the CIA
killing a president or possibly no no
they they they love the CAA now they
love the FBI now like because they
control it but but took it over that the
the general umbrella left not leftists
like Fringe leftists still don't like
them they hate the United States
institutions yeah I get that but like
the liberals who used to pretend to
align with the left now absolutely but
um I wonder
is is this our last presidential
election
and I mean that in a hyperbolic sense
like is this is this going to be a
tumultuous and strange election that
breaks the the routine we've expected of
every four years in that it's not going
to be Joe Biden
the way the reporters are coming after
him the way the hunter Biden scandal is
going I'm hearing that that Biden's the
Joe's lawyered up already yeah maybe
Michelle Obama and David Newsome yeah
maybe Michelle's going to win but
Michelle she's going to dominate I don't
know I don't know I think that's what
Alex was saying he thinks he's gonna be
Michelle he was like is he going to be
Gavin Michelle or Michelle Gavin and I
I've been saying something similar to
like if Michelle Obama ran I said this
and then Obama will run the run the
office from his basement in his sweats
just like he joked about wanting to do
but but the question is do they have the
wherewithal to maintain the machine that
they failed to maintain for the past
eight years I think so I think
Michelle's the kind of person that can
be shocked out of it like her and Barack
are like asleep in the machine but I I
sense they're a single person
we're talking about look Donald Trump
should not have got elected it was
supposed to be Hillary Clinton and Trump
won because they screwed up bad
2020 comes around and they went insane
in their panic and Desperation to the
point where Boston Globe reported they
entertain the possibility of the West
Coast seceding from the union of trump
won again
now 2024 is coming around and Trump's in
the polls doing really well and they
know bidening got it so what do they
have you're right last ditch lastage
effort Michelle Obama but can even with
Michelle Obama
can they muster up the machine they need
to defeat Donald Trump if they can do it
Biden they can do it with Michelle that
was during coven
yeah but I like Michelle Mann and I'm
not even like a I'm not registered
Democrat or any of that but I I really
like that girl I think she is really
smart she's the reason Barack ever had
the confidence to become president she
has two great kids as far as I can tell
what does that have to do that is it's
about I think she'd be a good leader I
mean I I I think she's stable I think
she's willing to to say no to the crap
the bad stuff and and overturn the
what's gone too far Barack Obama
killed a 16 year old American kid I know
that's that's political command but I
don't like it see I I think Michelle
Obama will be a despotic tyrant with a
smile on her face just like we all are
they all depends
I'm not gonna get behind them and this
is the funny thing because I got the
DeSantis people who are all mad at me
and they lie so much holy crap they're
like Tim's they're tweeting about
claiming that I said Trump will
magically change his behavior and become
the best president I'm like when did I I
said he has a slightly higher chance of
firing people that's it I want to see
the corruption dismantled and is Trump
going to be the greatest president of
all time no on foreign policy maybe but
that's just one specific area there's a
lot of bad things he did in foreign
policy as well but in terms of firing
corruption ripping it from the system
Trump Wants Revenge I'll take what I can
get doesn't mean he's gonna be good no
the problem with that is that he
announced it that he announced he was
gonna go in and arrest all these people
like
but you know but that's why they won't
let them win because you can't show your
hand beforehand and be like these are my
secret plans once I get in I'm gonna end
your career you're like no they're not
gonna let you get in dude he he did play
ball the first time around he tried yeah
he tried playing ball I thought it was
gonna be a traditional American
presidency that was his big
miscalculation yep and he he brought in
people we didn't like and we criticized
him for it and he kept people on that he
should have fired and we criticized him
for it because he thought I'm gonna work
with him to mess my bellies I'm gonna do
my agenda and they were not having it
now he's like I realize the truth they
must be dismantled yeah but I and I'm
not saying he's wrong or right I'm not
saying he's wrong but he should not in
my opinion he should not have said that
out loud he should have went in there
won the job and then did it without
telling anyone he was coming because if
they know you're coming they're they're
going to fortify but they did they
accused him of being a traitor working
for the Soviet Union not even Russia the
Soviet Union Jonathan Shake goes on
MSNBC and he's like Trump might be a
Soviet it's like so he doesn't exist he
didn't say that explicitly he said Trump
may have been a Russian asset going back
to the 80s okay that would mean he was a
Soviet asset you know but like meanwhile
the Dems in this country there was a
letter from Ted Kennedy to uh the
Soviets asking them to help uh fight
against Reagan in in the early 80s like
it was always the Dems that it aligned
with uh with the Soviets and they were
always Partners didn't Bernie Sanders go
yeah in the Soviet Union so it was great
yeah that's crazy like people are
disappearing dying being beaten they
were there were there were plenty plenty
of people in the west that were very
prepared to write apology uh pieces for
the Soviet Union there were people and
the at the New York Times I forget the
guy's name he was writing during the the
holiday more Notch well the holiday more
yes but there I'm thinking about uh I
was thinking about something that
someone was writing just writing glowing
pieces about Stalin and he was at the
New York Times like writing great pieces
about Stalin while Stalin was you know
killing millions of people and throwing
people in in the gulags and while the
gulag system was at its at its peak
there were people in the west writing
glowing pieces about Stalin because they
believe in the ideology and they
believed whatever you need to do to get
to the Communist Utopia to remake man as
a socialist was fine that's the the
reason why
why the the left always makes excuses
for the horrors and atrocities that the
left does is because if we just get past
this hard part if we just get past the
part where a bunch of people die then
we'll have remade Society into a
socialist Utopia and then we'll have the
perfect society that we all where
everyone has what they need and Etc so
it'll be worth killing off this many
people or whatever because once we get
through it once you get through this bad
part then the Utopia is on the other
side it's just that you never get
through it the bodies just pile up and
pile up and that's why you end up with
dozens of millions dead look they want
to eliminate free radicals to create
what I would describe as a organism
system they want the people who are like
I would like to be an accountant and
nothing more and then they want that
person to stay in their box and do what
they're told we're free radicals we're
bouncing around doing all this crazy
individualism stuff that's bad for the
expansion of the machine into a higher
state but it is good for America
it's good for it's good for Humanity the
world for human progress a decentralized
system is better than a centralized one
yeah because then it's no Elon Musk said
this right because then it's better it's
not decentralized because then uh if it
not everything goes to hell right not
everything fails at the same time you
want diversity when it comes to Nations
you don't want one world government
let's think about this way
little single-celled organism runs
around lives it's life it's fine it eats
it lives it dies it happens if the cell
next to it dies it's fine ah but in a
human if a clump of cells in one part of
the body fails every other cell dies off
that's the risk of a centralized system
if a human dies it causes damage to the
greater system let's say the human's a
farmer Farmer dies okay well someone's
got to pick up the slack and replace
that that person that happens in a body
like normal a cell can die off and then
it gets replaced by another one however
if we centralize everything then the
risk of catastrophic Cascade failure
exponentially increases because you
cannot replace an accountant with a
plumber
within a decentralized system it's much
more it's much easier to fill gaps more
fluid like water and less rigid yeah I
guess you have an amalgam of a
centralized decentralized system so it's
just like a human body you have a brain
which is kind of a pseudocentralized or
area of the system you have a heart you
have a stomach all these like minor
centralization so like in any truly
decentralized system you have larger
nodes which tend to be seemingly a
little more of a central area where more
people are are coagulating but if one
node fails it can be replicated replaced
or the machine won't the whole system
doesn't collapse yeah you don't want to
rely on any one area of the system ever
if you have to rely on one area for the
system to function that's a big
vulnerability it's like we have two
kidneys if one fails then we might
survive you know we probably will with
one you know
think about that in terms of if I want
to centralize humanity into one big
machine one big system
you get one one centralized node failing
that can't be replicated and the Machine
will collapse Humanity collapses and
that has to build itself Back Up From
the Ashes I think decentralization works
way better in terms of everything the
speed of progress especially the
happiness of people in general the
Soviet Union didn't work people were
miserable they were starving they were
miserable and the greatest Point made is
when the Berlin Wall came down which
side ran to which side it's fairly
obvious why would you want to live in a
system where you're just suffering the
whole time you wouldn't now the idea of
the Communist says get rid of the free
radicals find the cogs who are blind and
happy to be blind and they will be happy
and they will owe nothing
yeah I always thought it was weird how
they went after the Intelligentsia and
in the Soviet Union I was like of course
why why oh they're the ones that would
challenge me radicals gotta get rid of
the freeways man one antioxidants one
problem with um decentralization is in
finance if you truly have a
decentralized financial system then
there's no organized currency and
without organized currency it's almost
like we don't really have a country
without a a unified dollar so if
everyone had their own currency Ian coin
fill coin like it I don't know I think
that would be a lot more chaotic and
therefore potentially destructive of a
world to live in so in that I I value
currency uh centralization but I don't
want a central bank controlling all the
flow you need checks and balances yeah
you're gonna have a central system so
like you need to audit the Federal
Reserve and any anything that's
attempting to control the money or get
rid of it
um yeah you could but change it for
something else like that Indiana Jones
move where he like puts the the bag of
sand
you want a new I don't know I think the
Federal Reserve is a control mechanism
that creates slavery through ignorance
yeah people can't you
you do work
you save you save object of value object
of value retains value you can later
trade it because you did the work to
produce the value with the Federal
Reserve quantitative easing the mass
bringing of money and the controlling of
interest rates you do work thing of
value slowly degrades over time so you
have to have to keep working forever
so crazy dude they loan money to the
banks
at interest then the banks loan that
money to humans to us to the people that
don't work at the banks for more
interest
so then they just so that the people at
the bottom have to pay back this huge
interest chunk to the bank so that they
get a cut then the pay back the rest of
the interest to the Federal reservist
Bank these Global Bankers so that they
take the rest of the cut they that they
don't that's not how money works anymore
they don't you don't have to pay back
money to the Federal Reserve the Federal
Reserve just just like they take money
out of circulation and and Destroy
you're not paying it back they're just
destroying the actual money is created
by Banks upon the issuance of debt so
every time federal reserves will offer
promissory notes to the banks nobody's
promise to pay back there is a little
bit of that but it's it's not the
typical means of money at Monetary
expansion yeah the reason like well just
like like three or four years ago the
feds started paying interest to banks on
their reserves and it like last year I
think it was like 300 billion dollars in
interest payments that the Federal
Reserve paid two Banks nationally so
that they would sit on reserves it's a
totally new thing and it's inflationary
but it's the Federal Reserve makes no
sense anymore they're operating in all
different types of ways I got an easy
one for you I was out the whole week so
I didn't get to promote it but go to
timcast.com scroll down to the menu you
can see we have a documentary section
and you can watch Game of money oh dude
by Ben Stewart explaining how this all
works and breaking down the financial
system and right so this is what an
infinite Reserve currency where they can
print infinite amounts I think it went
back didn't it go back someone mentioned
they rescinded that policy it was like
an emergency I don't know it was March
2020 that they put it on but I haven't
seen a documentary on it since they did
that so I'm looking forward to seeing
you talk about the debt ceiling game of
money
the way the Federal Reserve used to have
fractional Reserve lending where they or
Banks would have so you could loan a
hundred dollars to someone and they
could loan out ninety dollars
every time you swipe your credit card
you've created that money yeah there's
no the money is created the money given
to that grocery store you swipe your
credit card for 100 bucks that money is
manufactured and dropped in their
account there's people that make the
argument that it's not even technically
money that that you have in your wallet
or in your in your bank accounts and
stuff because it's not a commodity so
money's supposed to be a commodity it
doesn't represent anything except for uh
the the promise of the the government so
I don't I don't have uh a deep knowledge
on this type of stuff but the difference
between currency which is just
facilitating Financial transactions is a
or that is a different thing to money
which some people say only gold or
something that has value like Bitcoin or
whatever would be considered actual
money and then now you're just left with
paper currencies that are facilitating
transactions but not actually holding
any value of their own so
yep
yeah there's no savings savings is gone
in order to save now you have to cross
your fingers that something will retain
value maybe gold
yeah you need to make money to keep up
with inflation if you want to produce
any sort of save you need you need to be
at least increasing your your money at
the the rate of inflation that's it's
it's it's a it's a
it's kind of sad but I think there's a
lot of issues that come with massive
population expansion of humanity that
have allowed evil people to exploit to
maintain massive levels of power
we don't have to always use money there
used to not be money I don't know how
many hundreds of thou tens of thousands
of years ago it was a humans invented
the idea of currency at one point monies
money's good because otherwise you got
to find someone that wants your fish or
your chicken or your eggs yeah because
you're looking to trick because all
money does all money is is something
that has a a right now it's a it's a
subjective value but it has a value and
that you can use to trade for other
things because without money you can't
like you got a chicken and you want
shoes you gotta find someone that has
shoes you like that also wants your
chicken but then you also got to figure
out how many chickens you need for shoes
exactly you know money is just a
lubricant money is just a loot money
just lubricates social transactions and
that's one of the things that that
people don't understand when they talk
about people like like uh um Elon Musk
he's got so much money and blah blah
blah Elon Musk is worth that because he
owns Rockets like actual rockets that go
into space and he owns cars and he owns
factories that makes car make cars he
owns he owns stock in the company and
that's that's where the value is it's
not in the dollars that he has the
dollars are just just a means of
transaction it's just accounting do you
think that we're headed towards like a
future where we evolve away pass money
where we have infinite access to
electricity I re I I object to the term
evolve because it implies that it's it's
somehow a biological result that'll or
something biologically that would happen
and human beings don't evolve unless
there are outside forces making them
that do that make selection like it
takes outside forces for natural
selection to happen so it's not actually
Evolution like you may you can call it
progressing or you can call it changing
but when you say evolutionary evolve not
the right word it comes to mind that
there is an outside force creating a
change in the species maybe from one
strata you would be like hey they
evolved to do a new thing but from
within it doesn't feel we're not
actually it's not yeah human beings
don't you and that the problem with that
is the idea is like oh it need we need
to remake man and it comes back to the
problems with socialism you cannot
remake man and if you and the last thing
that humans want to try is to create
conditions to force an evolutionary
response because that means dead people
right you don't get an evolutionary
response unless you have generations and
generations of dead people I'm so worked
up about the banking the global banking
system like it got to this point where
it's centralized at this bank for
international settlements that these
these small group of people are
attempting to control the world with
money like are we just done are we
headed toward yeah exactly like if you
want to talk about God on earth like
that's the money people have misused
misaligned and care so much about making
money that it's more about you know
being connected with God for some people
but like I I just can't I can't imagine
a just system involving money seeing how
it's gone in the last 600 years that it
would ever be able to redo it and start
it and make it this time it's going to
work out Bitcoin
but then it just falls into the hands of
somebody in the middle I can't it
doesn't but how do you know somebody
doesn't own 51 at this early on I feared
that at this point I do not fear that
really how do you know those because
they're so big the competition is
international competition between
adversarial Nations is too much that
they're they're they're trying they're
fighting over but it does not work but
like if if they could print up Six
Trillion bucks tomorrow from the Federal
Reserve and buy Bitcoin with it there's
only like two trillion dollars worth of
bitcoin on Earth so like it's possible
they've printed up 5 trillion in the
last seven years it just seems like a
pittance of potential for for
centralization they could they could
they could there are ways to destroy
nothing's invincible
but I just
whether it's Bitcoin or an advanced
technology of a similar method the
decentralized blockchain advanced
context is strong advanced technology
being everyone has infinite electricity
would that be even worse would we create
monkeys with insane amounts of power and
we would just kill each other off like
everyone had like a vibrating generator
that gave unlimited electricity could
create water with it you could fuse
hydrogen you could create food with it
um you can make oil out of it and
destroy the world you think if everyone
just got that it would just destroy
everything if you could convert if you
could create instant Fusion to create
water you'd create the massive
displacement of the ecosystem then
there's an argument that centralization
on purpose is valuable that we're
actually creating Gatekeepers
intentionally to Keep Us Alive yeah we
need to build Rockets
decentralization is is a faster method
of developing Technologies and
preserving Society it's a better means
of coming with ideas to avert crises as
opposed to one centralized committee
right
there is a benefit in a military context
of having an emergency Emperor right you
need someone to make quick decisions and
just get the job done ASAP but that's
simple knowing your borders knowing your
troop counts that makes sense what if a
meteor is headed towards the Earth
having one guy be like okay everybody uh
build Rockets is not probably not the
best idea having each different Nation
put all their resources towards trying
to find a way to divert or destroy the
meteor and and then coordinating in a
decentralized manner is probably a more
effective means in my opinion
so so similar to like a decentralized
system we have large nodes on the system
you know perme or coordinating but not
controlled you know like here's the way
I look at it
one gigantic
fist trying to smash through through a a
gate or water being poured through the
water will find a way to seep through
the cracks and make it to the other side
that's decentralization all the
different droplets trying different
methods of breaking through and getting
the other side versus Hyper focusing one
at one point and then hitting the wall
and missing you know you know what I
mean oh yeah oh yeah yeah let's go to
super chats and see what the audience
has to say so smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the share
with your friends become a member at Tim
guest.com because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show which is uh
oh boy we got Snopes snope said uh were
they chanting we're coming for your
children true they were and we're going
to show you videos that you're going to
be upset about seeing but they need to
be shown and um yeah we'll talk about
what they're doing at these events at
timcast.com in just about 25 minutes
yeah a lot actually a lot of text me
during the show about that exactly uh
the Snopes thing yeah exactly yeah I'm
not and interestingly it's funny because
uh this video's gone so viral and
there's no watermark on it so a lot of
people properly attribute it like
Marjorie Taylor green posted the video
and it says from Tim cast news she did
it the proper way really do appreciate
it I'm not gonna cry you know we were
getting I was getting hit up and they
were like oh look all these people are
downloading the video and they're
stealing and I'm like dude the point of
having a journalist go film it was so
that everyone would see it what is
credit it do for us you know what I mean
like I'm not gonna make money off the
video we posted and said everyone quick
look at this now give me money no no
it's more like look at it and tell your
friends but that being said 10 years ago
me and my buddy Isaac put together an
app called tagley which no longer exists
but I still have on my phone which when
you take a photo or video instantly
applies any text the date and location
to it and so I'm like okay we need to
bring this app back and get a lot of
this app so the way the app works is you
walk around take a picture the picture
that is instantly saved to your camera
roll will say whatever text time date
location so you can put at timcast on it
and then you take a picture click upload
and the bottom left of the picture will
have the tag and the metadata has all
the information in it too and then we
were working on another function of it
where it would create a fingerprint for
every photo to to create an encryption
key basically proving the rights and
ownership of it basically like what nfts
sort of became or sort of are and we
were talking about doing this 10 years
ago and uh we ran out of money so we
stopped Isaac uh we got to bring it back
because a lot needs it but anyway let's
read
all right
I'm not your buddy guy says great trick
in beating voter fraud is by doing
ballot harvesting can you imagine the
consequences of two ballots existing for
the same person yet two different
signatures
well yeah just get everybody to vote
it's that simple huh purple says welcome
back Tim Friday morning show was amazing
and this Friday's show is going to be
equally as amazing I I think we should
we should publicize our guests for the
culture War we don't do it for IRL
because people can cancel but I think
because the point of the culture war is
to bring on two prominent personalities
to have a discussion debate Etc I think
Monday we should start the promo for
Friday so we're gonna what's gonna be
live in the morning Friday morning we
got two really awesome guests and we're
gonna have a very heated silly but fun
and serious in a lot of ways
conversation and uh we're doing it every
week so we got some really big ones
planned we got some celebrities coming
yeah literally be crazy I think it'll be
heated but they're not going to be
disingenuous and yeah no I think yeah
this one's going to be real like the the
genuine idea for the show with Emma and
Sean was when she has to come on a few
weeks before I was like yeah we'll have
we'll find somebody to have a
conversation with and she agreed and
then I I just could have figured they
was going to make it about me or
whatever but the point of the show is
not for being it's not the Tim pool
debates random people show so we have
two people who are coming on and I'm
mostly going to be moderating and you
know but I'll be a part of the
conversation it's not going to be as
rigid of a debate format but we've got a
left and a right person they're coming
on and fairly prominent on each side
it's gonna be a thousand times better
than it's gonna be like
so esoteric
you know it's going to be like I think
it'll be higher higher level political
discourse yeah but I do think there will
be some invective yeah I mean that makes
that makes it interesting yeah a little
bit yeah yeah all right where are we at
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I showed
my affluent white female liberal ants
the old dude tighty whitey video I think
it's disgusting told me to stop showing
it if they still can't grasp how it's
them voting them is what brings this
debauchery
I mean the point is he showed to him and
said you support this and say no but
okay so we agree with each other I
thought that's good thank you we just
wanted to make sure we're on the same
page it's it's to open the door to be
like look if you if you like this video
then I don't think we can agree on
anything oh you don't like it you see
now we got something we can work
together on
and then ask them do you think we should
stop it from happening or do you think
we should allow it to happen what do you
think
let's grab some more Super chats
purple says the French roast is Bomb not
gonna lie cast proof for life it all is
ridiculously good I can't even I I can't
even I just say I can't even I gotta
tell you the Appalachian nights we we
got samples we we mix it with try
different blends we put this blend
together for a robust dark blend it's
very dark
it is it is the best coffee ever it's
your favorite one favorite coffee period
Well like of anything I've ever had
we've we've got a we've had a bunch of
different coffees come through this
place and I'm like that's good this one
okay here's what I do in the morning I
make a cup of coffee and I slowly drink
it over the course of two hours what do
you put in it heavy cream that's it I I
make coffee and then I put in like a
fourth cup of heavy cream like like an
absurd amount of heavy cream yeah very
very creamy it's good it's the way to
drink coffee to these days oh it's like
you know it's keto I cut out the sugar
and then I do a lot of fats you stir
hard or use one of those stir seeing
those spinning things just stir the
spoon real quick and then drink it
the Appalachian nights is so good I'm
like chugging it in five minutes no
sugar you don't add sugar no no no are
you crazy no I do coconut water so
there's sugar that's okay there's only a
little bit that's fine it's like a
milkshake I do appreciate it um we've
we've basically got rid of our live
sponsors and we're only doing our own
company
because we want to build stuff we want
to build stuff you know so go to
casper.com if you want to support us and
buy coffee that is mind-blowing and I
gotta be honest the rise with Alberto Jr
is also insanely good it's a very light
roast I like that one that one's sold
out pretty quick because it was like the
first one too well it's got Roberto Jr
on it he's a celebrity you know
everybody everybody had to get the
Roberto Junior one he is a celebrity it
is it is still available and the current
cups are on their way so those should be
uh available soon and then we have
sleepy Joe decaf unwoke and um I think
we're doing Mr bocus pumpkin spice
experience delicious and then I think
we're gonna do an espresso roast focus
with Mr bocus yes
those were that those are all ideas
all right where are we at
let's grab some more oh yikes
okay Sam says there was an underage girl
between 8 and 10 years old that
participated fully in the Madison Naked
Bike Ride Madison police say no laws
were broken happened earlier this month
yeah that it is illegal but the cops
like it like that's the thing
there are a lot of laws in the books
they don't enforce like in Wisconsin I'm
sorry in West Virginia for instance the
law says any card game is illegal
hosting a card game is illegal wagering
in a card game is illegal but they've
decided that Pokemon is legal and we all
think about that like oh yeah this is
Pokemon cards and it's like okay well
kids put up money to enter a contest to
win cash value on a game that consists
of at least some chance the law
explicitly forbids that no one's going
to get arrested or charged for doing it
right so there are laws that clearly
Define a thing and like yeah but that
one's okay and so what's happening here
is the cops are basically saying yeah
they don't care they don't care back to
blue baby
all right guric atuvu says I just
discovered timcast thank you for
everything we had the same problem in
France and we don't have the free speech
to talk about it thanks for what you're
doing you are all amazing be honorable I
really do appreciate it and I was
saddened to see the video where the
pride marches in France tear down the
French flag unlike Francis school you
know what scares me
I told the story before I went to the
Bahamas I was on a cruise
we went to Nassau and I gotta get off
the boat they're like you have X amount
of hours to go and check out the city
and I'm like this would be really cool
I've never been here before and there's
going to be like local fair and local
experience and what do I see Gucci
Starbucks Dolce Gabbana Hard Rock Cafe
I'm like
is this what the world will be no I like
the idea to go to France and get
baguette I like the idea you get
schnitzel in Germany I like the idea you
get you know you go to Ireland bangers
and match Guinness and all that stuff
but everything's homogenizing and
everything is going to be
this generic plastic corporate facade
everywhere you go and that is horrifying
yeah I feel like it can't it can't
sustain that I can't imagine that can
sustain I like the version
I like the first I like being able to go
to another country and being like oh
this is what they do it's good fantastic
but I went to Chile South America or
Peru actually at the time and all it was
was chicken and rice white rice and
chicken I was like that's everything
every green vegetables like no more
white rice white right white rice white
rice I'm like dude I need healthy food I
can't only do so much of the same thing
so there's that value I'm so sick of
being the The Devil's Advocate the other
let's just move forward together
all right Nathan C says the rainbow flag
comes straight from Satan and it's an
inversion of God's promise not to
destroy us trust me I know these things
I'm deep
this guy made a comic of Charlie Kirk
Elon Musk and me and it says we are
afraid of rainbows and I'm like
you know this is how you know these
people don't actually watch the show
because I have consistently advocated
for the flying of rainbow flags as a
Reclamation of God's covenant I told
Sheamus I'm like I told him like hey why
don't you put a rainbow flag behind it
was I don't know I might send the wrong
message and I'm like would you really
give up
God's like a symbol of your religion to
them and just against no take it back
reclaim it make them look people are
like it's a different rainbow you know
there's only so many colors what I was I
was joking and I said
June is American greatness month and all
these corporations are flying the symbol
of God's covenant they're changing their
profile pictures to rainbows to
symbolize to symbolize this is a
Christian Nation right I'm being
somewhat facetious but I'm basically
saying take the rainbow back it was it
was Christians to begin with why are you
just being like Oh I guess we won't use
it anymore are you serious no it doesn't
make any sense I like the idea of taking
it back it's just I think it's tough
because they control all the cultural
institutions it'd be one thing if you
just do it you see how
Phil was talking about how Emma comes in
here and she has to disagree with
whatever it is I say
just be that yes they put up signs
saying it's okay to be white and they
called it hate speech and it was
intentionally an innocuous statement
that that the the trolls knew they would
freak out over so what do you think's
gonna happen if a bunch of right Wingers
start flying rainbow Flags yeah they're
gonna be like oh no no we don't we don't
want to do that anymore yep that's I'm
I'm saying but that but that's what they
do they come on this show and they're
like we don't actually know what you
believed him at all and I'm like well I
love that watching her say things that
were just like provably false like that
you say like you will you claim you
called for a race war or something like
that and I was just like when I was like
what seriously it was just such a weird
like that's a crazy thing to say it's a
very crazy I'm like the mixed race guy
like that's the meme empty head yeah
completely empty head she she
embarrassed the hell out of herself and
did no favors for the majority report
really I thought it was great really I
mean I didn't love every word that came
out of everybody's mouth but I thought
the show itself was awesome yeah but do
you think that she did well and did
watching that make you think I want to
check out the maturity report because
those guys are on to something I I knew
who I knew her beforehand like I just
know who she is from watching so I it
was exactly what I suspect expected but
better because they got along really
well for like 98 of the show
who did you and Emma it was pretty
genial except for like there were a few
hot points but it's pretty much like
let's just talk about it because she
would go she would say something like I
think we should have socialized
Healthcare what's your position on
Healthcare I'm like you don't know it
he's like I'm in favor of what I would
describe as universal basic Healthcare
he goes oh I didn't know yeah it's like
did you like eat her own words well why
don't you make more videos about it I'm
like why don't I make more videos about
my random opinions I was like first that
was one thing she said we should talk
about more is getting homeless people
housing because then they get a shower
once you get a shower you can get a job
and that came from somebody who's never
owned a house well my friend works in
San Francisco with homeless that's a big
part of her what she does too I will
tell you two things Ian having worked
for a large network of homeless shelter
nonprofits they don't want houses no you
got to get them for the people that want
them you can't skip force people unto
them no none of them want them there's
not many of them that's why they're
homeless something now okay but I won't
be absolute maybe a small percentage
really just don't want to be homeless
but uh in my experience 98 of the
homeless people we encountered did not
want to have a house yeah and wanted to
be outside and and did not want jobs and
would explicitly say I know that if I
take your shelter offer you're gonna
give me a curfew
and you're or you're going to lock me in
or you're gonna drug test me that's the
way I get crazy house and yeah there's
nothing about it but you know how Ellie
is you can live every day every every
part of the year in in La I have no
problems especially getting money from
the government you're you're setting and
you can go and hang out you can't
maintain these houses no this is the
this is the funny thing about people
being like housing first just give the
homeless houses and I'm like yo
houses don't just exist yeah it takes an
insane amount of work to maintain them
that's why you have slumlords and We
complain about slumlords because they
don't maintain the property they're
renting out
so a lot of people don't realize this
too it's like in order to live off being
a landlord you probably gotta own 10
properties because you do not make that
much off renting out a house no no you
you you make a profit but then you have
to work you have to make sure like yo
I've had a property we when we moved out
of New Jersey we rented the property and
I get I had a rental management company
take over I was like just run it I guess
and then I ended up selling it to people
who are there I'm like look man
I don't want to be a landlord I don't
want people renting from me you don't
make a lot of money off it I'm not
trying to be a landlord I just owned the
house and figured somebody should live
in it and after all the problems we had
things break we pay to fix it I'm just
like you don't really make money off
this I was like guys do you want it buy
it like You're Gonna Save money I don't
want to be a landlord but these leftists
don't understand this they think
landlords sit around and do literally
nothing now it's possible you get
wealthy enough where you own a hundred
properties they're all being run by
management companies and you're making
at that point you're you know if you own
100 properties depending on where those
property properties are you're probably
a millionaire well you're literally a
millionaire owning all those properties
but you're generating a million bucks
and at that point yeah okay I can get it
massive conglomeration stuff like that
but a lot of work has to go into it a
lot of work has to be paid for it so
when people are just like we should
house homeless people it's like yeah
okay yeah it's like feed the hungry it's
feed them what yeah exactly and for how
long like forever until there's 900
billion of them like what you know
let's grab some more Super chats CeCe
says the left is a theistic religion
they worship intersectionality they just
haven't named a god yet Ergo it's a
non-theistic religion demiurge just as
Jesus lived without sin theirs will
exist with all of their intersection of
of all oppressions
it is really really amazing to be honest
how they've created this like Bizarro
Christianity they live they believe that
their original sin yeah they will they
believe that there's there is at least a
sec a segment of the left that like
worships like the the nature and stuff
like that they're gnostics that believe
that like God is actually the devil and
there's a God that's above the god of
the Bible and he was imprisoned in like
in reality he was broken up into into
shards and he's imprisoned in reality
and so when you hear people say like
there's a little piece of God in all of
us that's a heresy according to
Christians that's saying that oh I am
that's that's like a gnostic cult belief
that's like The Infinity Gauntlet that
they shattered the gems were like
shattered and God was stored in the
identity gems all over the Universe I
know it's it's not it's not the same
thing it's like it's like part of like
the Gnostic hole the nasty heresy you
can read up g-n-o-s-t-i-c literally yeah
it's a real thing it's a real religious
belief that that a lot of people
are that people act out even though they
don't realize that they believe it
whenever you hear people say there's an
end of History that's when God realizes
that he is it's when man realizes that
he is God and then all of the conflict
in in the world goes away because man
realizes that conflicts are are just
representation different representations
of the same thing it's a whole Gnostic
religion and and most people that are on
the left don't realize it but they're
they're they're acting out a religious
religious beliefs Gabriel Lopez says I
was an atheist for 15 years thought I
was really smart to have it all figured
out science explains everything I was
wrong humbled myself found God
Christians will write all along I'm done
with anything alphabet Mafia related it
is not good for anyone that is an
awesome story it is great uh
I I relate to it I don't believe
Christians will write all along I
believe they're right about a lot I
think there are a lot of uh really smart
philosophers and theologians throughout
history Christian thinkers who thought
about the universe and God and morality
and they came up with an extremely
intelligent things and many of these
things we want to live by today I I'm I
am not a Christian however I do I think
there's there's just smart people
however I will say uh I think watching
The Passion of the Christ was very good
it gave me a political understanding of
of the ideas around the passion era when
all that stuff was going down and uh
like the the human element of what the
story was not the religious element
because because all my life I've been
told this religious story of what it
meant from a perspective of God having a
son do these things then I watched the
passion for the first time and I'm like
now I understand the human element of
why they did what they did to Jesus
because you know and you know Satan is
in the movie and there's a religious
obviously it's religious but I thought
that was really interesting to seeing
like Pontius Pilate saying if if this
man's Innocent but if I crucify him then
they're going to revolt his father's
Revolt but if I don't then the people
who hate him will Revolt so what do I do
and it's like a piece just like the cops
in New York City exactly exactly the
guards running in to like stop the
Revolt because they're angry about what
Jesus was saying did they portray Jesus
to like having like just be have not
gone insane but like just crushed by the
weight of the burden like does it start
off where he's already in prison or is
it the the the uh Sheamus needs to be
here but no it starts off in the garden
and yeah no no not guess uh yeah yeah
and and it walks through the whole
passion so it starts in the garden and
ends with um actually ends with him
Rising uh no that's like the end scene
oh right right right sequel coming out
yeah they're doing a sequel the
resurrection that's hilarious I mean how
are they gonna do that I hope he because
the same actors and he goes to hell
after he dies his Spirit Goes to Hell
and he saves Souls saves souls and then
he then he's risen so like if that's an
action movie where he's like dressed up
like Rambo and he's in hell like
slaughtering the demons and he saves
people there is a lot of violence and
brutality in that movie that's why I
haven't watched it man I I it's such a
great thing it's a Content topic but I
don't like Gore I just don't I just
avoid it unless it's necessary but what
I was saying to shame is after watching
it I was like watch that movie without
knowing anything about religion and it's
the story of a guy who was teaching
people and preaching love and so the
powers that be felt threatened by what
he was teaching so they had him killed
and it's like very political yeah dude
the emperor I think you don't have an
emperor but anyway my point is uh in
terms of the religious stuff I can tell
you there are a lot of really good and
strong and important ideas and smart
thinkers
and and they gave us important Concepts
I always cite blackstone's formulation
which is rooted in the story of Sodom
and Gomorrah it's a foundation of this
nation and how we became the most
powerful and uh in many ways the most
just don't get me wrong very unjust a
lot of ways too but I think the the
foundation of this country with the the
fourth fifth sixth amendments man and
the Second Amendment come on
dad just brilliant Brilliant Minds
Brilliant Minds
all right let's uh the quartering says
massive announcement at 2 p.m Central
tomorrow glad to see Timmy back and
sounding healthy but yeah I am Shilling
out because it's going to be huge well I
wonder what it will be Jeremy from the
quartering so that's 3 P.M Eastern right
oh no wait yeah 3 P.M Eastern yeah three
p.m Eastern yeah all right well we'll
we'll look out for it
Blaine says hey Tim I'm a professional
hvacr technician I can fix your air
conditioning we've had like
we've had a company come out
every month because it breaks down every
week yeah I think the issue is the
building's too big
too big of building
so it the the filters break and then the
machine overloads and then something
happens to it
and like it's hot upstairs but cold
downstairs the Heat's obviously rise
it's cold across the hall that's why we
opened the door because like the AC in
there is nuts the funny thing is in
Carter's Studio he's directly under it
so let's see yeah when people turn the
AC on even a little bit his turn his
room is 50 degrees oh my gosh we need to
figure this out I mean look being in the
booth when it's when it's cool is all
right you know it is being in the booth
when you're yelling and the Booth's hot
that's no fun man yep yeah but with the
uh the new studio we have decentralized
AC units nice cool and uh
I gotta tell you
we finally get the concrete done
and this is the the so we we one of the
so someone reached out to us on our
members Discord where they're going to
be hopefully they're coming in and
they're going to do the work for us glad
to have uh made made their acquaintance
we're like hey we want the the concrete
it was it's fresh poured concrete we
need it polished and sealed and we want
it sealed I would say like a Home Depot
floor
you know not not not slippery but you
know you can skate on it they say okay
they used a seal that made it sticky as
sticky can be and so we're like yo this
was ridiculously expensive why did you
do it wrong and they're like we didn't
know and it's just this is what happens
every time
you tell them this is what I want you
got it and they do the wrong thing and
this is what keeps happening to us
across the board everywhere can you like
override this the sealant with something
else you got to polish it again and
reseal it and they're like oh well if
you want it that way we'll do something
else and I'm like
okay
first world problems I guess yeah I
guess but the problem is we're trying to
launch the studio and fix all of the
problems so we can run this machine
better
and the other first world problem I
guess you can't get people who can do
the job yo this building's been two
years in the works two years
insane and and and I gotta tell you
with all due respect even the company
that reaches out to us they're like we
can be ready in three weeks and I'm like
it's never gonna get done never yeah oh
it'll get frustrating and it's gonna be
amazing yeah maybe in a year even with
the the building we're doing for the
coffee shop it's like we go in and we
say okay here's our preliminary plan
then they say it's a historic building
you got to do these permits we do the
permits okay now you got to do an
inspection here we do an inspection okay
now I got a problem here we're doing
another problem here I it really does
feel like they're just trying to rip
money from us and at some point there's
no point trying to invest in West
Virginia you know what I want to do is
build a climbing wall in there do we
have room that we we that's part of the
plan yeah a rock climbing wallet
yep
on the works
all right de monovich says I'm part of
UE local 506. we are currently on strike
over our contract with webtech in Erie
Pennsylvania they want to be able to
change our health benefits and price at
any time they also want to have a
10-year progression for any new hires to
get max pay
well I hope you win I'm kind of torn on
uh Union work stuff because I had
negative experiences with all my unions
I was held back by them
I would there was no path for me as an
individual under Union contracts I'd go
to my boss and be like I'm always on
time I pass the test I do this I want
this they say
talk to your union rep and I'd be like
what they can't give me a promotion or a
raise and they'd be like neither can I
you got a Union contract to deal with it
I'm like I quit
I don't want to work here there's no
movement
and it was like
do you guys I like the idea that the
average person is protected is great but
then the ambition the ambition is
curtailed
so are you guys have union experience uh
and not in a union but I've dealt with
working with unions and I find them to
be difficult and that's putting it
mildly was there a musician Union no no
it's it's usually like uh loaders and
stuff like that at is specifically in in
New York City dealing with the the
unions at places like the Nokia Theater
or whatever if you walk out on for some
reason if you're in a band and you walk
out on the stage to get something from
like the back line or whatever the union
guys
you can't push if they're if you want to
bring something to the stage from the
from the truck you you can't push your
own crate there had the union people are
we the hindered progress massively we we
had we were getting a venue and I'll
keep it very vague and we had security
issues nope Union
has to go through them
we show up and I'm like I want to check
out the stage before the show nope Union
and I'm like I'm putting on a show we
got a thousand people come I need to
come on stage nope so I went we went
around into the seats into the actual
room and then just jumped up onto the
stage I have to check it out there for
that and then they yelled out yeah and
then they yelled at us and started
screaming at us how dare you what do you
think you're doing and I'm like I paid
money I need to know what the stage
looks like and what were our plan is
nope you need to scout it for safety too
you need to be aware of your
surroundings you need to survey the
stage all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you really
do like it because it really does help
word of mouth is the most powerful way
to help podcasts grow head over to
timcast.com become a member because the
members only uncensored portion is
starting in a few minutes and it's gonna
be oh it's gonna be gross and spicy but
you don't want to miss it so again
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcastirl follow Tim cast news at
timcast news on Twitter because boy
where this viral clip went we're not
went crazy and a lot Elia who's our
reporter on the ground he's covering
these stories you can follow me
personally at timcast Terry do you want
to shout anything out no just uh thanks
so much for having me on guys you can
find out more about my group American
principles project at
americanprencilsproject.org
right on I am Phil Labonte lead singer
of all the remains the band is All That
Remains uh what is it atrhq on Twitter
I'm Phil that remains on Twitter uh you
can find All That Remains on Spotify
Apple music uh YouTube uh I want to give
a quick shout out to the guys at tnvc
for the uh hookup on the night vision
they're super cool nice have you looked
at comets yet no no satellites awesome
not yet I haven't I haven't gone to look
for satellite yet you don't need to look
for them just when you look up you just
see it all yeah I mean Crossland very
happy to see you guys keep doing your
best and I also have a final Super Chat
from Joe Schilling ask Terry what his
favorite pizza place is Saint Giuseppe's
Heavenly Pizza in Moline Camanche and
Coal Valley Illinois oh it's my family
pizza place that's my brother Joe all
right so Hey Joe you got a shout out
congratulations you guys it's in Moline
huh yeah you guys do you do square cut
uh yeah strip cut yeah yeah rectangles
yeah it's great I tell people people in
Chicago it's not deep dish that's
tourist pizza that's right and it's this
it's the square cut Quad City Style
Pizza yeah that sounds good it's good
it's got sausage that's spicy it's
ground up it's underneath the cheese
it's like steamed it's malt barley crust
it's phenomenal yeah that's um yes can
they freeze it and overnight it yes they
can let's order some right okay I'll get
I'll get it I'll get you guys hooked up
that's beautiful all right guys see you
later see you tomorrow and I am
search.com excited for this after show
because it's a lot's work so that'll be
cool yeah we're not gonna see you
tomorrow we're gonna see you in a few
minutes over at timcast yeah just a
little bit we'll see you soon guys all
right thanks for hanging out everybody
we'll see you over there